nhá. Thì thông thường với bài với bài
toán classification ấy chúng ta hay gặp
dữ liệu nó bị ăn nó bị imbalance và cái
class chúng ta quan tâm hơn ấy thông
thường sẽ là cái cái class cái class
thiểu số đúng không? Ví dụ như là email
spam hay là không đúng không? Thì class
spam là class thiểu số mà chúng ta
thường chúng ta sẽ quan tâm hơn class
này người bị có bị Covid hay không. Nếu
người người bị Covid là thiểu số chúng
ta cũng quan tâm hơn hoặc là xem mọi
người ta bị bệnh ung thư hay là cái gì
đấy không thì cái class ung thư ấy cũng
là class số ch quan tâm hơn đúng không?
Đấy, thông thường như vậy nhưng mà riêng
cái bộ set go này nó là một cái trường
nó rất là đặc biệt là gì? Trong cái bộ
set go này nó có thắng hòa thua đúng
không? Trong thắng hòa thua thì cái hòa
nó có ít hơn đúng không? Thì thì cái số
lượng thì cái cái nó là class thiểu số.
Thế nhưng mà tuy nhiên với cái bộ CGO
này thì cái class thiểu số này lại là
cái class chúng ta ít quan tâm hơn. Tại
vì thông thường người ta trong thể thao
trong các cái mónn đối kháng ấy người ta
lại hay quan tâm đến thắng với thua hơn
đúng không? Thế nhưng mà ok đấy là cái
mình nói về cái điều khác biệt giữa cái
bộ set go này với hầu hết cái bộ ăn
imalan khác. Thế còn với thế còn với cái
với cái trường hợp của bộ set này ấ nếu
mà chúng ta muốn tăng cho mô hình nó
focus hơn vào cho cái cho cái class hòa
ấy đúng không thì cho có nhiều cách lắm
đúng không? Ví dụ chúng ta có thể làm
tăng cái trọng số của tăng cái trọng số
của các cái sample thuộc cái class hòa
đấy. Tức là gì? Ví dụ là ví dụ lúc mình
tính Lost đúng không? Ví dụ tính Lost
thì mình tăng gấp 10 lên đúng không? Tức
là cái tầm quan trọng nó sẽ gấp 10 những
cái khác. Tức là đúng cái ông dự đoán
đúng cái ông hòa sẽ được số điểm gấp 10
lần dự đoán những cái ông khác. Có nó có
nhiều cách lắp thế nhưng mà nhưng mà
nhưng mà anh sẽ cần phải xem cái code
của em xem là em em đã làm việc em làm
cái gì rồi nhá. Đấy nhưng mà sẽ luôn có
một cái điều này là gì là khi mình tăng
được cái performance của class hòa này
khả năng rất là cao là cái performance
của hai class kia nó sẽ giảm xuống.
Thông thường khi mà chúng ta muốn cải
thiện cái performance của mô hình trên
một class nào đấy thì khả năng cao nó sẽ
dẫn đến cái việc là các khác nó sẽ bị
giảm đi nên mình phải tính giá được xem
cái cái trade off cái sự đánh đánh đổi
xem là nó có đáng hay không đúng. Thế
nhưng mà trước mắt anh phải nhìn code
của em cái đã nhá. Ok.
Ok các bạn nhá. Thì hôm nay hôm nọ chúng
ta hai buổi gần đ nhất chúng ta đã cùng
nhau chúng ta làm việc với cái bộ
diabetes cái bộ về bệnh tiểu đường rồi
đúng không? Chúng ta cùng nhau sử dụng
cái mô hình để làm sao có thể phân loại
xem là dự đoán xem là một người có bị
tiểu đường hay không. Và buổi trước
chúng ta cũng đã thử một chút file
coding để làm sao chúng ta có thể làm ra
một cái app, làm ra một cái front end,
làm ra một cái UI để cho người dùng họ
có thể dễ dàng họ tương tác với cái mô
hình của chúng ta đúng không? Mô hình
mình xây dựng xong rồi, mình huấn luyện
xong rồi [âm nhạc] mình xếp cái mô hình
nó lại đúng không? xếp mình lại sau đó
thì mình đem đi triển khai để sau này ví
dụ là người khác khách hàng họ dùng đến
thì họ chỉ cần họ nhập dữ liệu vào thôi
đúng không? Họ không cần phải lo là
không cần quan tâm là rượu mình chuyên
đâu đúng không? Mình họ biết là họ tương
tác về cái ứng dụng của mình thôi đúng
không? Đấ tất nhiên là buổi hôm nọ chúng
ta chạy là cả server cả client đều chạy
trên máy của mình. Còn các bạn thực tế
là server các bạn chạy ở đâu đấy và các
bạn thuê AWS hoặc các bạn thuê Google
Cloud chẳng hạn đúng các bạn chạy trên
đấy. Do client là phía chúng ta dùng UI
để connect đến gửi request đến cái
server đấy đúng không? Thế nhưng mà về
mặt bản chất như nhau thôi. Nó chỉ khác
nhau mỗi là cái chỗ mình triển khai thôi
đúng không? Thế đây là nội dung của buổi
lần trước.
Đó là cái buổi thực hành đầu tiên trong
cả cái khóa này. Thì hôm nay sẽ đấy là
đấy là cái project đầu tiên mà chúng ta
thực hành.
Hôm project đầu tiên đã về bài toán
classification rồi thì tất nhiên là cái
project thứ hai này sẽ là về bài toán
reaction đúng không? Bài toán
classification với reaction về mặt bản
chất chúng ta đều là supervised
learning. Chúng ta muốn huấn luyện mô
hình chúng ta đều cần phải có rượu có
đánh nhãn. Nhưng mà cái sự khác biệt là
gì? Là với classification thì cái output
đầu ra là những cái giá trị rời dạc nó
có hữu hạn giá trị khác nhau và chúng ta
có thể đếm được. Trong khi với reption
thì nó sẽ có vô số giá trị khác nhau và
các bạn sẽ không bao giờ các bạn có thể
đếm được xem là nó có bao nhiêu giá trị
đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn muốn sử dụng
một cái mô hình để dự đoán
giá nhà chẳng hạn đúng không? Giá nhà là
một cái giá trị nằm trong một cái giải
vô cùng tận sẽ không thể bạn đếm được
xem là có bao nhiêu giá trị khác nhau
đúng không? Hoặc các bạn dự đoán là bạn
dự đoán nh lượng khí thải CO2 ở một khu
vực chẳng hạn đúng không? Thì lượng khí
thải CO2 nó cũng là một cái giá trị mà
nó có vô số giá trị khác nhau các bạn sẽ
không đếm được xem là có bao nhiêu giá
trị tổng cộng đúng không? Đấy thì đấy là
ví dụ của bài toán re. Thì hôm nay chúng
ta cũng sẽ làm với một cái bài toán như
vậy. Thì bây giờ để làm về bài toán này,
chúng ta sẽ cần có một cái bộ dữ liệu.
Cái bộ dữ liệu này thì mình up trên mình
up lên trên Google Drive rồi từ buổi đầu
rồi. Nhưng mà đây mình sẽ gửi lại để cho
bạn nào các bạn chưa kịp down thì các
bạn lấy luôn đây. Các bạn đỡ phải ngồi
các bạn đi tìm lại nhá. Cái bộ này tên
là bộ đây là bộ đây là bộ student score
bộ về điểm của học sinh. Cái bộ này thì
nó mấy mình vừa gửi trên Zalo nhá. Bạn
nào các bạn chưa lấy trên Google Drive
về thì các bạn lấy luôn trên Zalo các
bạn đỡ phải muốn mỏ mẫm nhá. Mình sẽ mở
cái file này ra trông như này. Nếu mà
các bạn mở bằng Excel trông nhìn nó sẽ
hơi bị shí này. Tại vì là tại vì là cái
khoảng phân định của nó là nó dùng dấu
phẩy đúng không? Cái này thì mình format
lại thì cũng được thôi nhưng mà thôi
đằng nào thì mình tí nữa mình cũng sẽ mở
trong trong ID mình mở bằng ID mà đúng
không? Mình mở bằng PAM hoặc là mình mở
bằng VS Code đúng không? Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ mở luôn ở bên trong được chưa?
Mình sẽ mở luôn mình sẽ mình sẽ viết
luôn một cái tạo luôn một cái script mới
nhá. Đúng không? Lần trước mình gọi là
classification rồi thì này mình gọi là
regressions. Được chưa? Đ cái su mới
này.
Tên nó là regression nhá. Được chưa?
Question này. Thế và mình sẽ của mình
đọc cái file này. Đọc cái file ờ đọc cái
file st score này ra. Được chưa? Cái
file này ấy. File này các bạn nhìn này.
File này thì các bạn có thể coi nó giống
như một cái file Excel. Nó là một cái
file Excel đúng không? Thì cái buổi lần
trước ấ chúng ta mở file, chúng ta mở
file CSV. Cái file mở file CV chúng ta
có cái có cái hàm gọi là hàm read set
này đúng không? Trong Pandas á đúng
không? Nó có một cái hàm là hàm read
set. Thế thì với file Excel ấy nó cũng
có một cái hàm gọi là read Excel. Thì
các bạn dùng cái read Excel đây các bạn
sẽ mở thôi. Đấy nhưng mà nó có một cái
có một cái này các bạn nhớ nhớ chả nhớ
thì thôi. Tức là thật ra trong Pandas
này ấy những cái file CV về Excel ấy các
bạn mở chéo cho nhau được. Tức là các
bạn có thể dùng read Excel để các bạn mở
file CSV cũng được. Mà các bạn dùng R CV
để mở file Excel thì cũng ok cũng chả có
vấn đề gì cả. Đấy thì bây giờ thử cho
các bạn xem nhá.
Như
đâu nhở đây nhá. Bây gi mình sẽ viết cái
script mới này nhá.
Import đúng không? Andas spd đúng không?
Đ vẫn câu quen thuộc đúng không? Đọc
rượu vào này đúng không? Mặc dù cái file
của nó
mặc dù cái file của nó nó là nó là cái
file st score này các bạn đọc bằng read
Excel cũng ok. R CV cũng ok. Đây mình
thử nhá. R CV này. Được chưa? Mình cho
cái tên đổi cái tên này rồi student
score
đấy nhá. Được chưa? Đấy đúng không? Mặc
dù nó là file Excel mà mình mở RV thì
vẫn được chưa? Đ mình sẽ b này được
chưa? Lệnh click chuột phải này được
chưa? Chọn execute selection invitent
console hoặc là các bạn in thẳng ra cũng
được. Đây mình muốn xem cho nó linh động
thôi. Được chưa? Chờ một tí thì các bạn
thấy là góc dưới bên phải nó sẽ hiện ra
một cái bàn. Những cái bà các bạn sẽ để
các bạn xem được cái data này.
Đây chờ một tí nhá. Đây. Mở file đây.
Cái bảng của mình như này. Được chưa?
Đây rượu như này. Được chưa? Đây là cái
bộ rượu của chúng ta. Cái bộ rượu này
liên quan đến điểm của học sinh ở đâu
đấy. Đó chả biết ở đâu đúng không? Thì
nhìn qua một tí cái bộ này nó có đúng
1000 đúng không? Hàng mà đánh từ 0 đến
999 này có đúng 1000 như thế này. Được
chưa? Tức là mình có 1000 record, mỗi
record là đại diện cho một học sinh đấy.
Một học sinh hoặc là một sinh viên gì
đấy đúng không? Chúng ta có chúng ta có
tám cột đúng không? Nói qua có tám cột
này. Cột gender là về mặt giới tính. Cột
raceity là về chủng tộc đúng không?
Partial level of education là trình độ
học vấn của phụ huynh. Lunch thì chắc là
cái suất ăn trưa nó là xuất gì đúng
không? Xuất tiêu chuẩn hoặc là xuất
cái suất free và xuất được giảm bớt đi
đúng không? À test preparation code tức
là kiểu là học sinh này có tham gia
những cái lớp gọi là lớp gọi là lớp
tiếng Việt tiếng Việt mình gọi là cái
lớp gì nhở? Lớp kiểu mình học trước khi
thi ấ lớp kiểu lớp ôn thi đấy đúng
không? Đấy và mình có ba cái cột điểm
này điểm toán này, điểm đọc với điểm
viết này đúng không?
Thì đây là cái bộ rượu của chúng ta đúng
không? Thế thì bây giờ mình muốn là mình
muốn là xây dựng vào gọi là xây dựng thì
chúng ta muốn huấn luyện một cái mô hình
để phục vụ cho bài toán request đúng
không? Thì đầu tiên chúng ta sẽ phải
chọn cái target đã đúng không? Cái tagit
là cái mục tiêu mà chúng ta muốn dự đoán
đúng không? Thì các bạn thấy là rõ ràng
với cái bộ này chúng ta có chúng ta muốn
huấn luyện một cái mô hình reaction thì
chúng ta phải chọn cái tagit là một cái
giá trị nằm trong một cái giải liên tục
đúng không? Thì ví dụ đấy là chúng ta sẽ
có ba ứng cử viên đây. Điểm toán, điểm
đọc với điểm viết này. Được chưa? Nào
thôi mình cho lớp mình vote đi. Bây giờ
các bạn thích là ba cái cột này các bạn
thích chọn mỗi bạn các bạn chọn một cột
đi. Các bạn thích chọn cột nào là cái
tagit. Bây giờ cột nào mà đa số bạn chọn
thì mình sẽ chọn cột đây. Được chưa? Ba
cột này. Điểm toán này. Điểm đọc điểm
viết này. Các bạn thích dùng cái cột gì
là cột tagit thì mình sẽ chọn cột đấy.
Đa số thì chọn cột gì thì mình sẽ chọn
cột đấy.
Nào mỗi bạn cho mình một cái tên nào.
Xem cột nào cũng được đúng không? Ba cột
bình đẳng với nhau đúng không? Ba cột
bình đẳng chọn cái nào cũng được.
Rồi toán nữa. Mình dạy lớp này lớp số 20
21 rồi mà chỉ có đúng một lớp là chọn
khác điểm toán thôi. Còn tất cả 20 các
lớp còn lại bao gồm ở lớp mình là đều
chọn đa số là được cột toán nhá. Mình
lấy cột toán đúng không? Tức là bây giờ
bài toán sẽ là gì? Bài toán sẽ là mình
xây dựng một cái mô hình để làm sao có
thể dựa vào bảy cột còn lại đúng không?
Cột chủng tộc này, cột giới tính này,
cột trình độ học vấn của phụ huynh này,
cột ăn trưa này, cột học cái lớp học bồi
dưỡng thi ôn thi đúng không? Điểm đọc
với điểm viết để làm sao mình có thể dự
án được cái điểm toán đúng không? Đó là
bài toán reaction đúng không? Và thật ra
sau này mình muốn đổi thành bài toán
classification rất là dễ thôi. Ví dụ bây
giờ các bạn sử cái mô hình để dự đoán
giới tính chẳng hạn thì các bạn chọn cột
gender là cột tagit đúng không? Hoặc các
bạn muốn lấy cột race này là cột chủng
tộc này đúng không? Đấy thì các bạn thì
nó sẽ thành bài toán classification thôi
đúng không? Cùng cái bộ rượu đấy các bạn
chọn cái tagit khác nhau thì nó đã đổi
bài toán khác nhau rồi đúng không? Thế
thế bây giờ ờ à nhưng mà trước khi trước
trước khi trước khi làm cái gì đấy chúng
ta sẽ lại làm cái bước quen thuộc là
chúng ta lại in ra một cái report nhở.
Đi ra một cái report nhìn cho nó dễ đúng
không? Đây lại copy từ đây ra đây copy
từ đây. Đấy cái cái thường ngày xưa của
mình ý là hôm nọ hôm nọ lớp mình vừa bảo
có cái có cái thư viện gì mới mình quên
xử này. Hôm nọ có bạn nào bảo có cái thư
viện gì mới thay cho thư viện này nhở.
Đây mình vào lại trang chủ nó ghi cái gì
nào. Như nó ghi vào đây e data
profiling. Thư viện gì ấy nhở? Hôm nọ
các bạn nào vừa bảo có thư viện nó nó
vừa đâu ấ nhỉ?
Đây đây đúng không? F ừ F ở đây đúng vào
thử phát nhỉ.
Rename to à nó cũng rename rồi thế này
có phải cài lại không nhỉ?
Ừ thôi cài lại nhỉ. Cài lại phát xem
nhỉ. Mình cũng chưa hôm nọ bà ấy bảo
mình cũng chưa dùng cái mới nên mình
thôi cài lại phát nhha.
So
paste này uninstall. Ok
copy bên đây.
Yes. Này xóa đi đúng không? Th dùng bản
mới xem có cái gì hay không. Cái đầu
giao diện gì hay hay. Cái bản mới này nó
không bị giới hạn về phiên bản Python
nữa nhở. Cái cái cái cũ cái dat
profiling cứ phải dùng Python cũ cũ thì
thì mới chạy được.
Before after. Ừ cũng chả khác gì nhỉ.
Nhìn trông khả gì nhỉ? Cụ Pháp ch đi.
Okế thì đổi mỗi cái dòng import thôi.
Chả có gì khác cả. Đây
đang cài không sao đang cài mình import
sẵn luôn. Đây đây profiling này vẫn vào
lỗi á.
Đây cài thử phát xem lỗi gì. Có cho dùng
con nhỉ?
Documentations
không? Chắc là nó còn đây có cái gì hết.
Ừ trong sợ chả khác gì nhau nhỉ. Ở đây
tên nó vẫn đang dùng cái tên cũ này.
Mà sao cái này là cái n lâu ấy nhỉ?
Thôi không sao. Trong trong a trong lúc
chờ nó cài để không thán chết mình cứ
nói tiếp nhá. Trong lúc chờ cài thôi kệ
cứ cứ coi như là t mình mình ngồi mình
ấy xong rồi comment tạm đi nhá. Cứ để nó
cài. Đấy. Thế bây giờ mình sẽ đây lại
những cái bước cũ thôi. Cái gì đây? Đây
sau đó.
À ô sao lại sao cái này lại dùng lại yêu
cầu cả Python nhở? Sao lạ nhỉ? Python là
của deep learning mà. Số này nó dùng gì?
Python
à đây không không không vấn đề không vấn
đề không mấy cái trên thôi kệ đi không
vấn đề. Chọn là cái này sao mình dùng
cái môi trường này nhở? Mình dùng môi
trường chờ tí mình có một cái môi trường
khác. Môi trường này mình cho cái lớp LM
agent ra mìnhại dùng. Các bạn chờ tí
nhá. Mình đổi môi trường phát
đâu rồi? Không biết mình còn không?
Chờ một tí. Chờ một tí.
À
không cần đâu tại vì là bây giờ nó có
nhiều thư viện nó làm cái đấy lắm. Cái
webcopping ngày ngày xưa ấy cái thời của
mình ngày xưa hồi 2018 2017 ấy hồi nó
không có thực hiện sẵn mình phải dùng
cái kiểu là beautiful sub để web
scrapping chứ bây giờ dễ các bạn mà bây
có lm mà bây có lm nó web scapping nhanh
lắm không phải học đâu
không có rồi thôi không sao dùng tạm
được dùng tạm cũng được nhưng web scing
là dễ lắm
nhân điện cho em m s môi trường có tác
dụng động gì ạ như này nhá môi trường
tác dụng gì các bạn hiểu này ví dụ như
mình bây giờ mình dạy một lúc mình dạy
bốn lớp khác nhau
Mình dạy lớp machining, mình dạy lớp
deep learning, mình dạy lớp l mình dạy
cái lớp Python đúng không? Mốc lớp này
nó sẽ có những cái thư viện khác nhau.
Bây giờ ấy mà mình mà dùng chung một môi
trường ấy thì bây giờ mình phải cài tất
cả các thứ đây các bạn nhìn này. Ví dụ
đây này. Cái thư viện top vision này lớp
mình không cần. Đây là thư viện của lớp
deep learning. Cái lớp mà vừa kết thúc
trước lớp này ấy đúng không? Cái san này
cũng không phải của lớp mình. Đây cũng
của lớp diping nâng cao. Rồi hoặc là cái
lang trên này cũng không phải của lớp
mình. Đây là của lớp elm. Thế bây giờ
nếu các bạn cài tất cả một cái môi
trường ấy thì thứ nhất là cái môi trường
nó rất là nặng. Thứ hai nữa là sau này
nó có thể nó bị conflict, nó bị xung
đột. Xung đột tức là gì? Tức là lớp
machining này của chúng ta cần pandas
phiên bản phiên bản 3.10 đi. Lớp kia lại
cần phiên bản 3.12. Thế bây giờ làm sao
c chung một môi trường được. Thế nên là
thường ấ người ta làm những cái project
cùng về một cái topic ấ người ta sẽ dùng
chung cái môi trường. Những cái project
thuộc cái topic khác dùng cái môi trường
khác. Làm như vậy để đảm bảo là nó tránh
conflict và nó giúp cho cái việc các bạn
có thể ờ maintain những cái môi trường
này nó dễ dàng hơn. Thông thường không
bao giờ người ta dùng các bạn nhìn ví dụ
như mình đây các bạn mình dùng nhiều môi
trường khác nhau. Mỗi cái project mình
dùng những cái môi trường khác đây đúng
không? Ví dụ cái lớp LM thì mình sẽ mình
sẽ dùng cái mình lớp LM thì mình sẽ dùng
cái cái cái RAC này đúng không? hoặc là
cái lớp mình dùng cái sam này lớp mình
thì trước mình có một cái môi trường hôm
nọ mình vừa xóa xử đấy rồi hoặc là lúc
mình dùng clot thì mình dùng cái môi
trường này đấy hoặc là đấy mình có nhiều
cái môi nhiều cái môi trường khác nhau
đấy thì để đả bản nó tránh bị xụp đột
đấy thông thường khi mà de người ta đi
làm người ta thường người ta dùng nhiều
môi trường chứ không ai ta dùng một môi
trường cả được chưa sao anyway anyway
comback đây đúng không quan hệ bọn mình
thành cái thành công rồi đúng không hạ
thử nhá
như những cái khác như dùng vẫn hết ở
đây đúng cũng hai dòng này hai dòng này
đây
Export ra trong ấy. Mình cũng chưa dùng
thử xem là cái bản này nó có cái gì mới
không so với cái bản kia. Student score
gọi là student đi report được chưa?
Student report này. Được chưa? Rồi chạy
thử nhá. Chạy thử nhá. Cũng chỉ chạy một
lần thôi mà. Đúng cả đời cũng chỉ chạy
một lần thôi đúng không? Nào chạy phát
nào.
Em tạo ra cái report như nào.
Đây filing.
Cái này thật ra ấy
thật ra cái
cái cái
tên này là cái tên cũ đấy. Ngày xưa cái
cái đây khoảng 3 b 2 3 năm là người ta
dùng cái tên này. Sau một thời gian lại
chuyển ra cái data profiling này bây giờ
nó lại chuyển lại cũ. Tức là tên pack
thì là một kiểu nhưng mà cái lúc mà
import lại một kiểu khác mà thôi không
sao. Anyway cũng chả vấn đề gì.
Độ chạy nó hơi lâu một tí các bạn nhá.
Các bạn xem s xem vào đây xem mã nguồn
nó viết những cái gì không này. Đây đây
xong đây.
Rồi được chưa? Đâu rồi? Report đâu rồi?
Đây student report đây. Đ file html html
thì mở ở đâu cũng được đúng không? Máy
nào cũng cũng mở được rất là tiện. Đây
nhìn qua một tí nhá. Nhìn qua một tí
nhá. Được chưa?
Nào mình có mấy cái này cũng chưa có chả
có cái gì nhỉ? 8 variable đâu 100 đúng
chưa? Không có không có ông nào bị
missing cả. Rất quan trọng đúng không?
Không ông nào bị missing cả. Đỡ phải lo
đâu. Mà tí nữa lúc mình là code mình sẽ
giả sử nếu có missing value thì mình làm
thế nào nhá. Được chưa? Gender chỉ hai
giá trị thôi. Milale female nhìn vào qua
tí chắc là cũng chả có gì đặc biệt cả.
Đâ những cái category này cũng không có
gì cả cũng đều nhau. Được chưa? Và chủng
tộc AC CD E này. A BCDE đây. Categories
đây. Được chưa? Đây CDE này. Được chưa?
Level of education nó sẽ có sáu giá trị
khác nhau nế mình nhớ không nhầm đây.
Sáu ông này chưa? 1 2 3 4 5 6 được chưa?
Đấy. Some college này, associate degree
này, high school, sumal degree, master
degree. Được chưa? Lunch cũng có hai giá
trị này. Test prepation code cũng có hai
giá trị này. Đúng không? Đây là những
cái category xong rồi đúng không? Còn
bound numeric đây. Mình có cái histogram
đây đúng không? Bạn nào các bạn làm bài
thi IL chắc bạn cũng chả lạ gì cái
histogram này mà tất nhiên là histogram
trong IL nó sẽ thưa hơn chứ nó không có
như nhu này nhiều thế này phân tích nó
hết đúng không?
Rồi comment value này
với dạng số ấy thì các bạn cái common
value với cả x value này ấ nó sẽ chỉ hữu
ích cho dữ liệu dạng kiểu phân loại
thôi, kiểu catorical thôi. Còn num thì
hai ông này nó gần như nó chả tác chả có
tác dụng gì cả. Các các bạn có biết vì
sao không? Vì sao mà với giá trị dạng
numerical value thì hai cái ông common
không phải extrem cái common value này
với với dạng dụ dạng số ấy thì cái
common value này gần như nó chả tác dụng
gì cả. Các bạn biết vì sao?
Với categorical thì nó có tác dụng.
Categorical thì thì nó có tác dụng nhưng
mà với numeric thì gần như nó chả tác
dụng gì cả. Cái common value này. Common
value là cái gì? Common value là những
cái giá trị nó xuất hiện nhiều đúng
không? Xuất hiện nhiều ấy thì nếu mà
rượu nó là kiểu nó rời dạc thì xuất hiện
nhiều nó có ý nghĩa. Chứ cái ông này là
cái ông liên liên tục các bạn nhớ xuất
hiện nhiều ông này nó liên tục thì ví dụ
các bạn cái thông tin về giá nhà đi đúng
không? Thì mỗi một giá trị nó chỉ xuất
hiện có một lần thôi, nó rất là ít khả
năng xuất hiện lại nên là thường bây giờ
dạng số người ta ít khi người ta care về
value này đúng vẫn có quan tâm nhưng mà
thường ta sẽ quan tâm để ta phát hiện
outlayer thôi chứ còn value người ta ít
khi người ta nhìn cái này lắm nhá. Toán
này đọc này viết này. Được chưa? Đây rất
là quan trọng này đúng không?
Các bạn nhìn qua các bạn nhìn qua này.
Cái interaction này đây là mình chỉ quan
tâm đến hai giá trị thôi đúng không? Đây
là toán với cả viết này, toán với cả đọc
này. Nếu chỉ nhìn cái hình này các bạn
có cái nhận xét gì? Nếu các bạn chỉ nhìn
vào hai cái hình này các bạn có nhận xét
gì các bạn? Điểm toán với điểm viết này.
Cái distribution trông như thế này.
Không phải distribution mà cái
visualization trực văn hóa trông như
này. Toán với điểm đặp trông như này.
Các bạn có nhận xét gì? Nếu chỉ nhìn vào
hai hình này thôi. Các bạn có nhận xét
gì?
Nói chính xác hơn một chút nữa nào. Nói
chính xác hơn một chút nữa.
Có cái gì các bạn đoán là gì? Nó sẽ có ừ
nó sẽ có cái ừ có hệ đánh mạnh đúng
không? Nó có hệ Ừ đúng rồi. Nó có cái nó
có cái hệ số tương quan rất là lớn và hệ
số này nó sẽ dương đúng không? Ông tăng
tôi tăng, ông giảm tôi giảm đúng không?
Có nghĩa là gì?
Có nghĩa là làm sao? Tí nữa mình chọn mô
hình tí mình chọn mô hình mình sẽ thế
nào nhỉ?
Tí mình chọn mô hình mình sẽ nào các
bạn?
Đúng rồi. Chọn những cái mô hình đơn
giản, mô hình tuyến tính đúng không?
Những cái bộ dữ liệu nào ấy mà có một
hoặc là một vài những cái feature có cái
mối quan hệ tuyến tính mạnh với cả cái
target ấy thì mình nên chọn những cái mô
hình tuyến tính. là những cái hình nó
rất là đơn giản và nó làm việc rất là
hiệu quả với cái dữ liệu kiểu nó như
vậy. Được chưa? Đấy, dữ liệu này các bạn
ông này hai ông này đúng không? Mình
chưa nói đến đa cộng tuyến hay không
đúng hàng này chắc n đa cộng tuyến rồi
đúng không? Hai đọc viết k đa cộng cộng
đa cộng tuyến rồi. Nhưng mà nhưng mà
trước khi nói về đa cộng tuyến đấy đa
cộng tuyến mạnh đằng khác đúng không?
Nhưng mà anyway thì thấy là gì? Là mình
thấy là thứ nhất là có hai cái feature
có hệ số tương quan lớn lên tí rồi đã
đúng không? Đấy. Đây nhìn về cation. Cái
cation này các bạn chú ý này. Các bạn
chỉ nhìn vào cái những cột điểm, các bạn
chỉ nhìn vào những cái cột mà liên quan
đến ruệ dạng số thôi. Còn cái ruệ khác
thì nó không còn là coration đâu. Nó là
cái chỉ số khác. Ở đây người ta ghi nó
hơi bị miss dễ bị miss understanding một
chút. Cái question này nó chỉ áp dụng
cho di động dạng số thôi. Được chưa?
Nhưng mà nhìn qua đây các bạn thấy là
nhìn qua đây là nhì biết nó rất là cao
rồi đúng không? Nhìn qua đâ biết là nó
rất là cao rồi đúng không? Cặp đôi nào
cũng thấy nó rất là cao. Được chưa?
Missing value thì không có. Ngay ở trên
các bạn thấy là vẫ missing value này làm
gì có cái gì đâu đây đúng không? Zero
đúng không? Không bị missing value cái
gì cả. Được chưa? Dưới này đây đúng
không? Một vài 10 hàng đầu 10 hàng cuối
đúng không? Nhìn qua thì cũng không có
cái gì quá đặc biệt cả đúng không? Nhìn
cái tex qu lớn nhất là gì? Là có hai cột
điểm đọc với cả điểm viết và có cái hệ
số t lười với tit. Nghĩa là sao mình
chọn mô hình mình nên ưu tiên mình nên
thử mô hình tuyến tính mô hình đơn giản
là mình rất là hiệu quả với rượu kiểu
như vậy đúng không? Đấy.
Rồi thế thôi nhỉ cũng chả có cái gì đúng
không? Nhìn qua cũng chả có gì đặc biệt
cũng chưa chưa chưa chưa chưa có thấy
cái gì đáng nổi bật cả đúng không? Đấy
đúng không? Đấy thôi làm cái này xong
thì các bạn không cần phải lo trực vân
hóa nữa cũng không phải lo thống kê nữa
đâu. Một cái bảng này là bao gồm cả hai
rồi. Thống kê đơn giản trực qu hóa đơn
giản xong hết rồi đúng không?
Thế bây giờ quay lại code vục của chúng
ta thôi đúng không? Thì bây giờ report
thì xong rồi. Thế bây mình comment nó đi
đúng không? Để làm sao nó đỡ chạy nữa
đúng không? Đỡ chạy lại nữa. Thế thôi
comment đi này. Được chưa?
Bây giờ mình bắt đầu giờ mình lại làm
công việc quen thuộc thôi. Lại ngồi tách
dữ liệu
coration à đây đây đây đây nhá. Một là
mở vào đây.
Đấy mở đây này. Thấy không? Đấy này đấy
các bạn cứ chọn hai giá trị khác nhau
thôi. Cái bảng á bảng đây này. Đây đây
table này được chưa? Chỉ có nh những cái
cột dạng số thôi. Những cái cột khác nó
là nó không phải cion chúng ta hãy chúng
ta thường làm đâu. Được chưa? Đây này.
Nếu muốn xem nhá. Nếu muốn xem cái giá
trị dạng số này nó chính xác hơn nhá
đúng không? Tại vì nếu muốn xem cái cure
này ấy mà chỉ là quan trôi. Tại vì là
nếu không phải số thì cái qu trình nó
chỉ áp dụng cho số thôi. Nó không áp
dụng cho kiểu phân loại kia là nó là cái
khác rồi. Các bạn đừng quan tâm cái đấy.
Nếu các bạn chỉ muốn nhìn cái quãng số
nhá. Mình chỉ các bạn cách này đúng
không? Không cần phải dùng ờ thư viện
ngoài các bạn chỉ dùng luôn bandas thôi.
Nhìn nhá. Đây này. Mình nhìn này. Green
nhá. Data này đúng không? Mình sẽ cho
mình sẽ cho
ba cái cột này đúng không? M co nhá.
Reading score nhá. Được chưa?
Wting score nhá.
Score này nhá. Mình chung này.
Ok. Cái hàm này là đây v tắc của
coration cho coration các bạn nhìn này.
Nhìn này.
Đây đẹp chưa?
Được chưa? Đó. Tất nhiên nếu các bạn có
nhiều cột quá thì nó sẽ bị phất mất đi
nhưng mà đây mình chỉ có ba cái thôi
đúng không? Đây ma trận này đúng không?
C magic này chưa? Điểm toán là cái
target đúng không? Thì các bạn thấy là
điểm đọc với điểm viết là có cái hệ số
tương quan rất là lớn đúng không các bạn
nhớ nhá. Khi mình nói hệ số tương quan
lớn các bạn ngầm hiểu là gì? Có nghĩa là
mình đang nói là nó gần 1 hoặc gần -1
nhá. Gần -1 cũng là lớn mà gần 1 thì
cũng là lớn. Được chưa?
Rồi
thì em nói là writing với cả reading
đúng không? Em nói là writing reading
không? Tại vì mình chọn cột toán là cột
tagit mà đúng không? Tit với cả ấy thì
hệ số thương quang cao là tốt mà. Em
muốn nói về writing reading thế này nhá.
Đúng rồi. Cái reading với cả writing ấy
nếu mà nó có cái hệ số tư quan lớn nhau
nó đều không tốt tại vì nó thể hiện của
gì? Là của đa cộng tuyến đúng không?
Nhưng mà trước đừng có nói rồi cái đa
cộng tuyến ấy đúng không? Nếu mình dùng
cái mô hình tuyến tuyến mình có thể đ
loại bỏ đa cộng tuyến ok đúng không? Ví
dụ trong hai ông mình bỏ đi một ông. Thế
nhưng mà thật sự ấy nếu mà về cái đa
cộng tuyến ấy, nếu mà trong cái trường
hợp chúng ta chỉ có nhu cầu là chúng ta
sử dụng cái mô hình nó dự án tốt thôi.
Còn chúng ta không quan tâm đến cái việc
giải thích, tức là như này, nó giống như
kiểu này nhá. Bây giờ ấy mà các bạn làm
cái nhóm có năm người đi, kể cả các bạn
có hai ba ông nó làm việc trùm lấn với
nhau đi đúng không? Nếu mục tiêu của các
bạn chỉ là gì? là làm sao để làm được
một cái project nó càng tốt thì là tốt
đúng không? Thì việc các bạn chấp nhận
là hai ba trồng chân lên nhau cũng không
vấn đề gì. Miễn là kết quả tốt là ok rồi
đúng không? Thế còn nếu mà các bạn muốn
là tôi có thể có khả năng giải thích là
gì? Tức là sau khi tôi nộp bài xong rồi
làm tốt rồi tôi phải quay ngược lại tôi
phân tích xem là ông nào đóng góp nhiều,
ông nào đóng đóng góc ít thì lúc này cái
việc loại bảo đa đa cộ tuyến mới là cần
thiết đúng không? Thì bây giờ ví dụ đầu
tiên đúng không? Ví dụ đầu tiên mình sẽ
mình sẽ lấy là gì? là tôi chỉ quan tâm
là mô hình của tôi nó tốt thôi. Thì nếu
các bạn chỉ quan tâm mô hình của tôi nó
tốt thôi thì việc các bạn không đọc đọc
tiền nó cũng không làm sao đúng không?
Sau này nếu các bạn muốn dự cái mô hình
mà tôi muốn có khả năng giải thích tôi
muốn là xem là gì? Cái ông nào nó đóng
góp nhiều cho cái dự án này thì lúc này
các bạn mới cần cân nhắc đến đảo đa cộng
tuyến đúng không?
Có chứ có chứ not đúng không? Reading nó
là cái input đầu vào mà đúng không? Nó
là cái đầu vào mình có mà đúng không?
Tại sao lại không? Đúng không? Nó là
thông tin hữu ích mà đúng không? Trừ
phi. Trừ phi. Sau này trong thực tế cái
điểm đọc với điểm viết chúng ta không
biết thì lúc này chúng ta mới không dùng
đúng không? Còn nếu chúng ta biết chúng
ta cứ dùng đúng không? Với bộ rượu này
nó là điểm đọc với điểm viết nhưng mà
trong bộ rượu khác nó sẽ là những cái
khác nó sẽ không có hệ số tương quan lớn
với hôm nay đúng không? Hệ số tâng quan
lớn là cái thứ chúng ta mong muốn mà tội
gì đúng không? Có thì tội gì không? Rồi
đúng không?
Ok. Có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Thế nhá. Thế bắt đầu tách dữ liệu nhá.
Đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ tách chúng ta
tách theo bổ theo chiều dọc trước đúng
không? X sang một bên, Y sang bên rồi bổ
theo chiều ngang đúng không? Bộ chuyên
sang một bên, bộ test sang một bên đúng
không? Thế thì bây giờ nào lại bốn cũ ch
lại thôi đúng không? Tít đúng không?
Bằng M score nhá. Được chưa? Thế bắt đầu
mình bắt đầu mình tách này. Ừ đây đúng
không? Tách này đây đúng không? Tháng y
chang vào đúng không? Tháng y chang vào
này ch split chưa có. Đây trên split lên
trên này đây. Được chưa? Lấy luôn cả cái
winsert nhá. Tĩa kiểu gì mình mình cũng
winsert mà. Thôi lấy luôn tí đỡ phải
copy lại nhá. Được chưa? Rất như này. X
thôi đúng không? Chạy thử xem phát xem
có xem có gì không. Chạy thử này. Đúng
không? Xên test này. Bộ test là 0,2 đúng
không? Mình có 1000 sample tức là bộ
test nó sẽ là 200 sample đấy đúng không?
Bộ trược chưa? Chạy thử này. Thử này
xin đây nhá. Xe này đúng không? Mất cái
cột toán rồi. Được chưa? Ee đây. Đây
hiện nay có mất cột toán thôi. Được
chưa?
Đấy bộ test tự hơn đúng không ạ? Bộ
train thì các bạn có đây là 800 sle cho
bộ train, 200 sle cho bộ test. Được
chưa?
Rồi
thế đây là mình đã tách xong rồi. Tách
xong rồi. Chuyên bộ chuyên bộ test tách
ra rồi. Thì bây giờ bước tiếp theo chúng
ta cần làm là cái gì các bạn nhỉ?
Bước tiếp theo chúng ta cần làm là cái
gì nhỉ?
Làm là cái gì?
Ừ. Nói chung là tiền xử lý đúng không?
tiền xử lý thì các bạn nhìn này, cái bài
này ấy tiền xử lý nó sẽ phức tạp hơn cái
bài trước. Tại vì sao? Bài trước các bạn
chỉ có dữ liệu dạng số thôi đúng không?
Các bạn chỉ có dạng số các bạn dùng cái
standard scaler chẳng hạn các bạn dữ
dạng số thì ok đúng không? Bài này với
hai cột điểm đọc với điểm viết các bạn
cũng hoàn toàn các bạn có thể bê nguyên
cái standard scalar của bài trước sang
đúng không? Các bạn cũng thể các bạn bê
nguyên này đúng không? Stand scaler bê
nguyên sang và làm thì cũng ok thôi đúng
không? Đây nhá. Đúng không? Tí mình sẽ
bê ra mình cho các bạn xem thử đúng
không? Bê nguyên ra thì xong thôi nhưng
mà mình sẽ còn cả những cái cột khác nữa
đúng không? Mình cột có cả những cái cột
categorical nữa thì với những cột
categorical như vậy chúng ta sẽ không xử
lý dùng không không dùng sceller được.
Chúng ta sẽ phải dùng cách khác đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà thôi bây giờ cái gì
mà cứ quen thuộc thì cứ làm trước đã.
Thế có một cái điểm này với mình nói các
bạn rồi là cái gì? Cái bộ này ấ nó không
có diệu bị khuyết. Thế nhưng mà bây giờ
mình muốn như này tại vì là sau này các
bạn đi làm ấy ví dụ thường ví dụ cái
thời ngày xưa của bọn mình nhá là A2 nó
chưa có phát triển. Thông thường với m
mỗi mỗi một mỗi một data scientist như
bọn mình ấy, bọn mình sẽ có khoảng một
vài những cái script bọn mình hay dùng.
Ví dụ là bài toán classification mình sẽ
có một cái, bài toán reaction mình có
một cái, bài toán time series for
casting mình có một cái, bài toán
recommendation system mình có một cái và
mình và và mình sẽ thiết kế nó rất là
tổng quát để sau này khi mà có những cái
bộ dượa khác nhau mình chỉ modify cái
script này một chút thôi là nó có thể là
nó nó làm được rồi. Đấy kiểu kiểu như
vậy. Đấy là cái mà chúng ta muốn làm.
Thế bây giờ chúng ta muốn là bây giờ
chúng ta muốn thiết kế cái script làm
sao để sau này ấ chúng ta có một cái bộ
rượu khác vào. Chúng ta chỉ cần chúng ta
thay đổi một vài những cái tên của cái
feature thôi là chúng ta có thể áp dụng
được luôn rồi đúng không? Thì chúng ta
phải làm sao cho cái này chúng ta thiết
kế nó rất là tổng quát thì chúng ta mới
có thể làm được chỗ đấy. Tổng quát có
nghĩa là gì? Tức là sau này chúng ta có
thể chúng ta gặp những cái bộ rượu mà có
thể nó có những cái ô nó bị khuyết đúng
không? Nó có những cái ô nó bị khuyết là
những cái ô mà missing value đúng không?
Thì bây giờ chúng ta biết là cái bộ này
nó không có missing value rồi nhưng mà
hãy giả sử nó có missing value đi thì
chúng ta làm như thế nào đúng không? Hãy
giả sử chúng ta có missing value thì
chúng ta sẽ làm như thế nào
các bạn? Các bạn chờ mình một tí nhá.
Mình à mình cắm cái bút à vẽ ra để tí ch
có đoạn mình sẽ cần phải vẽ các bạn chờ
một tí nhá.
Rồi nhá đúng không? Thế thì để có thể
giải quyết được mixing value ấy thì
chúng ta sẽ phải phân loại ra đúng
không? Đầu tiên là mixing value nó nó nó
của cái feature dạng gì đúng không? Nếu
nó là feature dạng số, nếu nó là numer
feature đúng không? Thì bây giờ nếu mà
mình có những cái ô nó bị missing value
đúng không? Ví dụ trong cả một cái cột
ví dụ chúng ta có cái cột là cột đây này
chúng ta chạy lại chúng ta có cột là cột
điểm
điểm đọc đi đúng không? Cột là cột điểm
đọc đi. Đây
đây cột điểm đọc đi đúng không? Thế bây
giờ giả sử cái ô này, cái ô mình đang
bôi đen đây. Cái ô số 52 giá trị 52 này
đi. Ô này nó bị bị nó mà bị khuyết đúng
không? Thì bây giờ mình muốn mình muốn
giả sử bây giờ mình muốn điền vào cái ô
này mình làm thế nào? Mình muốn điền vào
đây mình dùng giá mình dùng giá trị gì
các bạn nhỉ?
Mình dùng cái gì nhỉ?
Mình dùng hoặc là
>> đúng rồi. Trung bình và là trung vị đúng
không? Trung bình và trung vị đúng
không? thường trung vị sẽ tốt hơn tại
trung vị nó ít bị ảnh hưởng với out
layer hơn đúng không? Thế thế thì trong
sơn á
nó có một cái nó có một cái class nó
chuyên làm cái cái đấy. Simple
input đây. Được chưa? Nó có một cái
class nó chuyên để nó trị cái chỗ mà
điền vào những cái ô bị khuyết này đúng
không? University
đúng không? Thì cái này ấ các bạn sẽ có
thường các bạn sẽ quan tâm đến hai thứ.
Bước một cái missing value. Cái missing
value tức là các bạn sẽ định nghĩa xem
là giá trị như thế nào được gọi là
missing value. Thì thông thường mặc định
ấ là ô nào nó trắng phớ nó không có cái
gì cả thì nó là missing value. Là ô nào
nó có những cái giá trị kiểu nan với non
ấy. Đấy thì nó sẽ được gọi là missing
value. Hoặc không các bạn có các bạn tự
định nghĩa các bạn định nghĩa là bây giờ
các bạn đấy là cái ô nào nó có dòng chữ
là là là
and chẳng hạn. Ví dụ các bạn có một cái
dòng chữ bất kỳ các bạn quy ước là cái
dòng chữ đấy nó là nó là nó là missing
chẳng hạn. Ví dụ như vậy đúng không? Đây
mặc định nó là non này hoặc nan các thứ
này đúng không ô nào nó trắng tinh không
có cái gì thì đấy là nặng đấy là missing
value. Được chưa? Đây là cái thứ nhất.
Cái này các bạn có thể mặc định cũng
được các bạn để không khai báo cái gì
cũng được. Bạn dùng cái mặc định có sẵn
thôi. Cũng ok được chưa? Cái thứ hai là
cái strategy. Cái strategy này đấy như
mình nói rồi nó có một vài cái. Thứ nhất
ấy là nếu nó là dạng số á numer đây này.
Còn nếu nó dữ dạng số các bạn có thể
dùng các bạn dùng min hoặc các bạn dùng
median được chưa? Thế còn nếu mà nó là
diệu dạng phân loại nó dạng phân loại
này, string này các thứ này đúng không?
Và lại các bạn sẽ dùng cái mod sequent
đó chính là mode. Mode là gì? Tức là ông
nào mà xuất hiện nhiều nhất thì tôi sẽ
điền vào đúng không? Ví dụ là tôi có cái
ví dụ cái cột ờ chủng tộc tí nữa đi đúng
không? Ví dụ các bạn dùng abde này ví dụ
tên có một c ô nó bị khuyết đi đúng
không? Thì tôi thấy là ví dụ là cái cái
cái group C là cái group mà có nhiều
sample nhất tôi sẽ điền luôn vào đây.
Được chưa? Đấy đấy cách để các bạn có
thể sử ô bị khuyết. Tất nhiên như mình
nói rồi, cái bộ diệ này của chúng ta nó
không có ô nào nó bị khuyết cả. Nên là
th cái này chúng ta có áp dụng vào nó
cũng chả khác gì cả. Nhưng mà như mình
nói chúng ta bây giờ chúng ta đ muốn sử
dụng cái script sao nó tổng quát nhất để
sau này chúng ta có thể chúng ta dễ dàng
chúng ta có thể modify nó chúng ta đem
nó đi áp dụng cho những cái bộ rượu khác
thì bây gi mình sẽ thiết kế nó rất là
tổng quát đúng không mình coi như là nó
có khả năng nó có rượu biện quyết đúng
không thì bây giờ tôi phải làm sao tôi
tính tôi xử lý nó được chưa thì chỉ dùng
rất là đơn giản thôi đây cũng import đây
cái limpin này import nhá đây
form skit learn ch in imputer đây m
imputer được chưa thấy Thế bây giờ mình
sẽ bắt đầu mình có một cái bước này. Đầu
tiên mình sẽ phải khởi tạo nó được chưa?
Imputter này bằng được chưa? Stranger có
thể dùng median được chưa? Median nó sẽ
tốt hơn so đấy là min được chưa? Sau đó
mình lại cũng
ấy lại cũng fish and form các thứ thôi
đúng không?
X
train được chưa? Nhưng mà mình sẽ chỉ
làm cái này với hai cái cột là điểm đọc
với cả điểm viết thôi. Được chưa? Tại vì
giờ chỉ có hai c này nó mới là dạng số
thôi mà đúng không?
Score được chưa? Writing score chưa?
Bằng
đây như này được chưa? Fure form này
được chưa? Bộ test thì mình cũng có thể
làm tương tự thôi. Được chưa? Đâ mình cứ
làm về bộ chuyên cái đã nhá. Test tí đã
tính sau được chưa? Tất nhiên cái dòng
này trong cái trường này nó chả nó chả
là có tác dụng gì cả. Thế nhưng mà trong
cái trường hợp khác thì nó sẽ có tác
dụng khi mà các bạn có những ô nó bị
khuyết. Được chưa? Im này được chưa? Só
đi mình bước tiếp theo mình lại đây lại
cái scaler này này đâu rồi
đâu ấ nhở đây này đúng không lại phút x
lại thôi đúng không sceller
đó đây mình chỉ áp dụng cho hai hai hai
cột này thôi cho hai cột à thừ thiếu cái
này này
missing value add random với cả not
random không ạ tức là như nào nhì không
hiểu nhỉ phân gia khuyết ngẫu nhiên có
phân ra khuyết
Tức như nào mình vẫn chưa hiểu nhỉ?
Missing at random và not random không nó
là missing thôi. Nó là missing thôi. Nó
là diện nó bị khuyết thôi. Được chưa?
Ch nó diện bị khuyết thôi. Tất nhiên sau
này các bạn có thể đi sâu vào các bạn ấy
nhưng mà th cái này nó cũng ch nó cũng
không đến mức phức tạp như thế đâu. Nó
cũng không đến mức phức tạp đến như thế
thôi đúng không? Tức là gì? Tôi chỉ đơn
giản là gì? Tôi đang muốn tìm cách tôi
điền vào những ô nó bị khuyết thôi đúng
không? Tôi không tôi chưa đến quan tâm
đến nguyên nhân nó bị khuyết làm sao.
Tôi chỉ quan tâm đến việc gì tôi điền
được vào nó. Được chưa nhá.
Standard scaler mình chưa có đúng không?
Chưa có này. Form chill đây. Sus scaler
đây. Được chưa? Chúng ta điền vào đây
scaler như này đúng không?
Mình extend thôi. Ví dụ như vậy được
chưa? Tất nhiên là
đây mình đang dùng mình chỉ dùng với hai
cột này thôi. Được chưa? Đây một và đây
các bạn nhìn nhá.
Cái việc mà chúng ta làm này là chúng ta
làm gì? Chúng ta đang áp dụng một vài cụ
thể là chúng ta áp dụng hai phương pháp
gì đó vào một vài cái cột của bộ trây.
Một bước này, hai bước này. Thì các bạn
nhìn này, cách chúng ta đang làm ấy nó
lại xâm giống như này. Đây các bạn thấy
mình vẽ nhá. Cách chúng ta đang làm ấ nó
giống như này này.
Nó giống như này nhá. Các bạn tưởng
tượng này nhá.
Các bạn tưởng tượng này ờ
mình đang có một cái bộ rượu này được
chưa? Data mình ở trên này
đúng không? Cái data này ví dụ là mình
chỉ lấy những cột dạng số thôi nhá đúng
không? Đầu tiên mình có một một cái bước
xử lý là cái bước inputer là bước này
này đúng không? Mình sẽ đưa delta vào
đây. Xong mình hứng kết quả ở dưới này.
Hứng kết quảở đây. Xong mình có cái bước
thứ hai ở đây. Mình lấy cái kết quả này
mình lại đổ vào đây. Mình hứng ở dưới
này.
Đúng không? Sau mình lại có một cái giả
sử mình có thêm cái bước thứ ba nữa đi.
Ví dụ như vậy đi. Mình lấy cả mình hứng
vào đây. Đây mình đánh phả hứng như này.
Được chưa? Đây đây các bạn nhìn này. Đây
này. Ví dụ mình giống y chang này. Được
chưa? Đây này. Initor là bước một nhá.
Đúng không? Nhét cái input vào đây. Hứng
cái output đồ ra này. Đúng không? Sau
lại tiếp tục cứ làm như vậy đúng không?
Làm như thế này ấy là các cái bước các
bạn đang rời dàng chúng nó với nhau đúng
không? Và các bạn sẽ phải gọi fit
transform rất là nhiều lần đúng không?
Cụ thể trong trường hợp này các bạn đang
gọi hai lần. Nếu giống như cái hình này
ví dụ các bạn sau cái bước stand scalar
các bạn có thêm một cái bước tiền xử lý
gì nữa thì các bạn sẽ phải gọi ba lần
đúng không? Nó vừa rời dạng mà lại phải
gọi vừa vừa nhiều nữa. Được chưa? Thì do
đó ấy bây giờ để có thể làm cho cái quá
trình sau này cháu trình huấn luyện nó
trình nó dễ dàng hơn chúng ta sẽ ghép
nối các cái thành phần này lại với nhau.
Tức là gì? Tức là bây giờ thay vì để
chúng là ba th phần riêng lẻ này, tôi sẽ
stack chúng lại vào nhau. Stack nghĩa
gì? Data thì ở trên này. Data thì ở trên
này. Được chưa? Tôi bây giờ tôi sẽ có ba
thành phần đ một đây. Như này này. Đấy
như này được chưa? Tôi chú lại thành
giống kiểu một cái pipeline thành một
cái đường ống. Đấy. Được chưa? Thế thì
bây giờ ấy khi mà tôi nhét dữ liệu của
tôi từ cái đầu tiên đi đúng không? Nó sẽ
tự động nó sẽ trôi qua cái đầu tiên, cái
thứ hai, cái thứ ba và nó sẽ đến cái
cuối cuối cùng này. Đúng không? Nó sẽ ba
bước như này được chưa? Tôi sẽ ứng kết
quả cuối cùng thôi. Thì khi mà các bạn
stack như này ấy, các bạn thành cái
pipeline này ấy thì sau đây các bạn chỉ
gọi f lần thôi. Nó tự động nó sẽ trôi
tuột từ cái âm đầu đến âm thứ hai đầu
ông thứ ba ra cái cuối cùng. Các bạn sẽ
không cần phải gọi thủ công từng bước
một như thế này nữa. Được chưa? Không
phải gọi thủ công từng bước một nữa. Nó
sẽ không bị rời dàng nữa. Nó sẽ thành
một cái đây không phải là ba cái khúc
riêng lẻ nữa mà nó sẽ thành một cái
đường ống hoàn chỉnh. Được chưa? Thế thì
trong siller cái này người ta gọi là đó
là pipeline đường ống
đường ống
dùng rất là dễ thôi đúng không? Một cái
a sequence of data transformers with an
optional final predictor tức là gì? Tức
là các bạn sẽ có thể stack nhiều bước
vào với nhau. Bước cuối các bạn nếu muốn
các bạn có thể dùng cái mô hình dự đoán
đ optional có thì có chả có thì thôi
đúng không? Tùy được chưa? Ví dụ các bạn
nhìn này, người ta stack này người ta
stack là hai bước này. Một cái bước là
bước xử lý về bước là bước mô hình này.
Đây là support vector machine dành cho
bài toán phân loại này. SV đúng không?
Support vector dành cho bài toán phân
loại. Được chưa? Mình thì mình sẽ chưa
vội ghép cái mô hình dự đoán ở cuối.
Mình chỉ ghép các cái bước tiền xử lý
thôi. Đây rất là dễ thôi. Cái P các bạn
chỉ cần có một bước quan trọng nhất là
gì? Các bạn khai báo cái step này. Cái
step này nó là gì? Nó sẽ là một cái list
của những cái tle. Mỗi một cái cái list
này bao gồm nhiều phần tử. Mỗi một phần
tử nó sẽ mỗi một phần tử nó sẽ là một
cái bước đúng không? Mỗi một cái bước
này sẽ bao gồm hai thứ. Một là cái tên
và hai là cái class tương ứng. Đúng
không? Cái tên này các bạn đặt gì cũng
được nhưng mà thường sẽ đặt sao để cho
nhìn vào người ta biết nó là cái gì.
Mang tính gợi nhớ đấy đúng không? Cái
đây cái mô hình đây ví dụ đây là cái
simple inputer hoặc là stand scaler. Đây
mình làm thử cho các bạn xem nhá. Rất là
dễ thôi nhá. Leon pipeline này nhìn nhá.
Đây nhá.
Learn
này nhá. Được chưa? Đấy, bây giờ mình sẽ
không gọi thủ công như này nữa. Được
chưa? Mình sẽ làm thành một cái bước
này. Bây giờ mình sẽ không định nghĩa
trúng rời dạc nữa mà thành một cái
pipeline luôn. Các bạn nhìn nhá.
Đây mình nhá. Xem nào. Mình sẽ gọi là no
transformer. Được chưa? Nom transformer
bằng cái gì? Bằng pipeline này. Này đưa
một cái step. Step không nên là như này
bằng này. Được chưa? như này. Đấy. Sau
đó thì mình sẽ
được chưa? Mình sẽ bắt đầu khai báo khai
báo những cái bước ở bên trong nó cái
toper này. Được chưa? Cái bước đầu tiên
là cái ví dụ cái simple imputer thì ví
dụ mình đặt tên tên mình gọi là imputer
đi được chưa? Mình sẽ nhách simple
imputter vào đây. Đây bước đầu tiên.
Bước thứ hai là đây scaner
mình gọi là
ừ scaler đi. Được chưa? này ch hai bước
thấy đây mà cái pip của mình bao gồm hai
bước đúng không thì bây giờ sau này mình
muốn xử lý cho hai câu điểm đọc với điểm
biết ấy là mình chỉ nhét nó qua cái pip
này thôi đúng không gọi một lần fit
trform form thôi là nó đi qua cả hai
bước được chưa ví dụ nhá exchange đúng
không lại bằng exchange này đúng không
heading score được chưa writing score
đúng không bằng
đây này được chưa
ví dụ mình ghi ghi là output nhá. Ví dụ
mình ghi là output nhá. Được chưa?
Former này được chưa? Đây mình sẽ chạy
cho các bạn xem thử nhá. Xem các bạn xem
output trông như nào nhá.
Mình chỉ làm về hai cột là điểm đọc với
điểm viết thôi. Đó thì nó là cột số được
chưa? Bây giờ thì các bạn à cái output
này output này nó chỉ có nó chỉ có hai
cột thôi. Được chưa? Đấy xử lý điểm đọc
hay điểm viết. Đấy được chưa?
Đúng. Hầu với cái giá trị nhìn chung nó
sẽ là khoảng từ -3 cho đến 3 đúng không?
Thế thôi. Được chưa? Tất nhiên như mình
nói rồi trong cái bài này ấy cái dòng
inputer này nó chả có tác dụng gì đâu
tại vì là mình có ô nào nó bị khuyết đâu
đúng không? Nhưng mà chắp những bộ khác
thì nó sẽ có tác dụng đúng không? Và giả
sử các bạn không phải chỉ có hai bước
các bạn có nhiều bước như này chẳng hạn
các bạn có rất nhiều bước nhưế này thì
cái việc các bạn dùng cái việc mà các
bạn dùng pipeline này nó giúp các bạn
các bạn đỡ phải gọi fix chan nhiều lần
đúng không? Và sau này các bạn tối ưu
thành một cái pipeline nó sẽ dễ hơn. Các
bạn tối ưu một cái đường ống dễ hơn là
các bạn tối ưu ba cái cục riêng lẻ đúng
không? Rồi
rồi đến đợt này có bạn nào có câu hỏi gì
không?
Đến đạn này các bạn có câu hỏi gì không?
Nó cũng tủy em ạ. Xử lý nếu xử lý quá
nhiều bước. Tức là mình chỉ xửng mình
chỉ xử lý những cái gì mình cần thôi. Ví
dụ có rượu bị khuyết thì tôi phải xử lý
rượu nó nó nó lệch. Tôi phải scaler để
tôi cho nó về cùng rain thôi. Tức là nếu
mà cái việc xí nó là cần thì mình làm
chứ không phải là mình cứ ngồi mình bôi
ra nhiều bước đúng không? Quan trọng là
không phải là ít bước hay là nhiều bước
mà quan trọng là cái bước xử lý này nó
có cần hay không đúng không? Nếu mình xử
lý các cái thứ cần thì nhiều bước không
này vấn đề ha. Ví dụ đây mình thấy nó có
hai cái cơ bản gì một là dệ bị khuyết
đúng không? Nếu tôi không drop ở trên
đúng không? Nếu ở trên tôi không drop
thì ở đây tôi sẽ buộc tôi phải xử lý
đúng không? Còn nếu các bạn ở trên các
bạn drop rồi thì thôi không cần xử lý
nữa. Được chưa?
Rồi đây là với dữ liệu dạng numerical
feature dữ liệu dạng số đúng không? Thế
nhưng mà đúng rồi đang dạng số thôi đây
này. Đang dạng số thôi được chưa? Chỉ
reading về với về với writing thôi. Mấy
ông kia sẽ phải kiểu khác được chưa?
Rồi dạng số thì nó dễ rồi. Tì dạng số
buổi hôm nọ chúng ta vừa làm xong đúng
không? Chỗ này chỉ có mỗi thêm là lắp
thêm cái inputer này thôi và đóng năng
thành một cái pipeline thôi chứ còn cái
bước xử lý này thì hôm nọ chúng ta vừa
làm xong rồi đúng không? Chả có gì mới
mẻ cả. Được chưa? Bây giờ quan trọng là
những cái ô còn lại cơ. Ô còn lại nó mới
là vấn đề đúng không? Bây giờ nhìn nhá.
Những ô còn lại thì thật ra chúng ta xem
qua report có lẽ nhìn nó dễ. Tôi xem đây
cũng được
nhá.
Exchange nhá. Được chưa? Được chưa? Bây
giờ chúng ta sẽ còn năm cột còn lại. Năm
cột còn lại nó không phải dạng số nữa
nên cách xử lý nó sẽ phải khác đi đúng
không? Tất nhiên là năm cột còn lại ấy
nếu chúng ta muốn xử lý rượu nó bị
khuyết ấy đúng không? Chúng ta có thể
dùng vẫn dùng cái imp inputer nhưng mà
bây giờ imputter của của mấy cái ông kia
ấy nó sẽ không phải là không phải là cái
median nữa thì median nó chỉ áp dụng cho
số thôi đúng không? Mấy ông kia thì các
bạn sẽ phải dùng ví dụ như các bạn dùng
đây này
simple imputter đây này cái đây. Ông kia
các bạn dùng cái most frequent ấy đúng
không? Này most frequent đây. Đâu rồi?
Most frequent này. Được chưa? Được chưa?
Tất nhiên again v cái bài này nó chả tác
chả có tác dụng gì đâu nhưng mà mình
muốn làm sao cho nó tổng quát để cho
mình có áp dụng cho bài khác được đúng
không? Most này thì cứ ông nào mà nó
xuất hiện ông nào nó bị khuyết thì nó sẽ
ví dụ đây mặc định là nó sẽ thay với cái
ông nào xuất hiện nhiều nhất đúng không?
Đấy nó có một m nữa là constant.
Constant các bạn sẽ định nghĩa xem là
nếu việc có ông nào bị khuyết tôi sẽ
điền về giá trị mặc định các bạn điền là
-1 chẳng hạn đúng không cứ ông nào bị
khuyết ví dụ có một cái ô dạng số cô
dạng số đúng không? Cứ ông nào bị khuyết
các bạn cho nó thành -1 hết cả. Ví dụ
như vậy được chưa? Mà cái này nó thì nói
ít dùng hơn ít dùng hơn
à nhá. này. Trong trường hợp ấy mà
missing value ấ mà nó không chỉ dựa vào
đúng rồi. Trong trường hợp mà missing
value ấy nó không chỉ dựa vào các cái
giá trị của cột đó mà nó còn phải dựa
vào giá trị của các cột khác nữa ấy đúng
không? Ví dụ như là thu nhập ở Hà Nội
của dây bốn người chẳng hạn đúng không?
Ví dụ các bạn có một cái cột là cột thu
nhập của gia đình đúng không? Nhưng cái
cột này bây giờ mà các bạn chỉ dùng các
bạn mà thu nhập mà các bạn chỉ ví dụ các
bạn ờ các bạn tính median hoặc là min
chẳng hạn đúng không? thì nó cũng không
chính xác lắm tại vì là thu nhậm còn dựa
vào nhiều yếu tố nó dựa rất nhiều yếu tố
thì trong trường hợp như vậy đúng không
trong trường hợp như vậy chúng ta sẽ có
cách là gì chúng ta sẽ dùng
gì dùng cây nearest ne để người ta điển
đúng không dùng cây nearestable ví dụ
bây giờ đang có một cái gia đình của tô
mỗi một hàng là một gia đình đúng không
cái gia đình của tô tôi đang bị khuyết
về cái thu nhập của gia đình đấy thì tôi
sẽ tìm xem là ví dụ là năm gia đình nào
nó tương đồng nhất với gia đình của tôi
đúng th cái khoảng cách cái distance nó
gần nhất đúng không tôi sẽ tính chung
mình của năm ông này được chưa? Đấy là
nếu trường hợp chúng ta muốn điền kiểu
pro kiểu premium hơn tức là gì? Tôi sẽ
không chỉ dựa vào cái cái nội dung cột
đấy, dựa vào nội dung của cột khác nữa
thì người ta sẽ dùng cây inable. Được
chưa?
Ờ tiếp nhá. Tiếp nhá. Có ai có câu hỏi
gì nữa không nào? Có ai có câu hỏi gì
nữa không nào?
Tiếp nhá.
quay ở đây thì bây giờ chúng ta bây giờ
chúng ta muốn
xử lý những cái ô chúng ta đây n sang
farmer xong rồi đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ
nói về chết rồi tên này lại tiên đặng
đóng lại giờ hơi ạ. Chúng ta nói về cái
cột khác nhá. Chúng ta nói về cái cột là
gender à xem nào. Cột nào đi.
Bây giờ các bạn nhìn này. À nói qua một
tí về
được có khó gì đâu. Nhưng mà mọi người
có thể về mọi người thử tự làm thì nó sẽ
hay hơn nhá. Mình đã gợi ý là dùng k
disable rồi mình có thể tự làm hay hơn.
Nếu mà tự làm không cái thì mai mình chỉ
cho nhá. Thử tự làm thì nó sẽ hay hơn và
nó sẽ nhớ lâu hơn nhá. Hiểu không nhá.
Thì các bạn nhìn này, nói về năm cột còn
lại nhá. Đúng không? Chúng ta các bạn
nhỉ? Nói về loại đi trước đi đã. Nói về
loại của năm cột còn lại đã nhá. Nói về
loại đi. Chúng không phải dạng số rồi.
Nói về loại các bạn nhìn này. Nói về
loại mở lên cho dễ nhá. Mở dễ nhá. Được
chưa?
Về loại thì đầu tiên này. Đầu tiên là
cột cột gender. Cột gender các bạn xếp
vào loại gì? Nó là categorical rồi. Nó
là categor. Nhưng mà trong categorical
các bạn có nominal, ordinal với bullin
đúng không? Cái này các bạn xếp là gì?
N xếp là gì các bạn?
Xế nó là cái gì các bạn?
Cột trend nó nó thuộc dạng gì đây?
Nó là gì các bạn?
Nominal ordinal bin
đúng không? Nó có hai giá trị thôi đúng
không? Bin được chưa? Ông này là bin gì?
Rồi ông ông này đây là gì? Nominal hay
là ordinal? Nó không phải bullin rồi.
Bulin chỉ có hai thôi đúng không?
Nominal hay là ordinal
nào? Nominal hay là
nominal hay là original ở đây?
Ôi cả lớp mà chỉ có một người trả lời
được đây là nominal hay original thôi
rồi đất ạ.
Cái lớp có hai bạn thôi.
Học đến buổi này rồi đấy. Nh các bạn
phải phân biệt cái này chớp mắt chứ đúng
không? Cái này có cái gì đâu các bạn học
lý thuyết học rồi đúng không? Chúng ta
bây giờ mà không tự phân biệt được thì
làm sao này chúng ta code được
ờ nomino đúng không? thì nó nhưng mà các
bạn này nominal là không có thứ tự đúng
không? Cho nên original là có đúng
không? Nhưng mà sao đây lại coi là không
có thứ tự nhở? Mình có thể mình lập đoạn
làm gì? Đây là thứ tự alpha mà đúng
không? A B C D E nó có thứ thứ tự đấy
chứ đúng không? Nó có thứ tự đấy chứ.
Sao chúng ta lại coi nó là nominal?
Sao chúng ta lại coi nó là nominal trong
khi nó có thứ tự mà
sao nhỉ?
À đúng rồi. Ừ.
Ừ. Không t chính xác là gì? Tại vì ABC
nó nó chỉ là cái tên thôi để nó phân
biệt ông này với ông kia thôi đúng
không? Nó phải có mang ý nghĩa tứ thứ tự
đúng không? Ừ đúng không? Đây là diệu
người giá trị nó là bình đẳng với nhau
về mặt ý nghĩa đúng không? Nên là nó là
nominal chưa? À gì nữa nhở? Đây
financial level of educations.
Nào nó là gì? Nó không phải bullin rồi.
Rõ ràng rồi. Nó là nominal hay là nó là
ordinal?
Nếu mà là ordinal đúng không? Tại vì nó
có một cái thứ tự gì đấy. Thế các bạn
thử hỏi hỏi các bạn nhá. Thế bây giờ
mình có
không copy được nhở. Đây
các bạn chờ chút. Sao mình không copy
nhỉ? Chờ mình một tí nhá.
Mình gửi trên a
mình gửi trên Zalo nhá. Thì bây giờ mình
có sáu giá trị khác nhau đúng không? Sáu
giá trị khác nhau này. Thế bây giờ các
bạn bảo nó là đủ. Ok nó là rồi đây mình
gửi trên Zalo nhá. Nó là rồi việc các
bạn giúp mình sắp xếp sáu cái giá trị
này theo một thứ tự nào được không?
Nó là original đúng không? Thì nó phải
có một cái thứ tự gì đấy đúng không các
bạn? Tùy các bạn sắp hết thự tăng giận
đưa giản luận tùy các bạn nhưng nó phải
có một cái thứ tự. Mình vừa gửi trên
Zalo tên của sáu cái giá trị này các bạn
có thể sắp xếp chúng theo cái thứ tự gì
đấy được không các bạn? Pết lại vào đây.
Sao mình không pết được nhỉ?
Mình còn không chat được luôn cơ.
Rồi có bác nào cho mình cái thứ tự
không?
Đây có sáu giá trị này đúng không? Mình
muốn xử lý đúng nó thì mình phải chỉ
đúng cái thứ tự của nó. Được chưa?
Thứ tự sẽ là gì? Bây giờ
nào cho mình xin cái thứ tự nào. Tùy bạn
tăng dần được giảm dần được tùy thứ tự
nà. là miễn là nó có cái thứ tự
à thứ tự gì đây?
Hm hm.
Bạn khác thì sao?
Sao nó chờ mình dịch qua một tí nhở?
High school thì là trừng cấp ba các bạn
nhở. Să high school thì sao? Să high
school thì sao? Să high school thì là
gì?
S high school là một cái trường cấp ban
nào đó đúng không? Thật ra thì high
school s high school các bạn cho âm nào
trước cũng được đúng không? Thậm chí các
bạn có thể gộp xuống lại với nhau đúng
không? Có thể gộp hai âm này lại thành
một class chung các bạn cho âm nào cũng
được đúng không? Xun cho các B nào đó
đúng không?
Ờ
ừ [hắng giọng]
được chưa? Mình cũng không rõ lắm là cái
này có phải là chưa tốt nghiệp không.
Theo tại vì theo mình nhìn cái tên này
thì nó chỉ đơn giản là một cái chứng c
đó tôi không biết cụ thể nó trường nào đ
nhưng mà anyway nếu mà hai này nó hai
này nhìn chung thì theo mình nó tương
đương nhau các bạn cho hôm nào trước
cũng được không các bạn gộp lại cái thì
cũng ok thô cái key point không phải chỗ
đấy point sẽ ở cái đoạn sau thế ờ
some college là một cái trường một cái
trường cao đẳng nào đó đúng không Sam
một trường cao đẳng nào đó đúng không
bacio thì là thì là đại học đúng không
master thì là cao học là thạc bạc sĩ đấy
đúng không? Associate degree.
Associate degree tiếng Việt mình là gì
hả các bạn? Cái màu cam này. Excitate
degree tiếng Việt mình gọi là cái gì các
bạn?
Dege tự Việt mình gọi là gì các bạn? Nó
là nó là cái loại bằng gì đây?
À đúng rồi, bằng liên thông. Chính xác
liên thông. Thế nào gọi là liên thông
các bạn nhở? Ở Việt Nam mình thế nào gọi
là liên thông các bạn? Thế nào gọi là
liên thông các bạn?
Thế nào gọi là liên thông nhỉ?
Ừ đúng rồi. Có thể là hai năm đầu các
bạn học c đẳng rồi các bạn ạ. Có cái thi
kiểu vượt cấp chuyển cấp các bạn làm tốt
thì các bạn lên học đại học thôi đúng
không? Ok đúng không? Ừ rồi thứ tự rồi.
Ok ba này đúng không? Cao đẳng này. Liên
thông này bachoello này. Master này. Ok
được chưa? Rồi. Thế thì
nói về tiền xử lý á nói về tiền xử lý
thì bây giờ à đ đ đấy mà đấy mà nói về
nó là cái loại gì đâ? Tí nữa tiền xử lý
thì nó nói tiếp sau đúng không? Thế thế
còn thế còn chúng ta còn cái gì nữa?
Chúng ta còn còn cái lunch nó chỉ có hai
giá trị thôi đúng nó là bullin đúng
không? Test test test preparation code
nó cũng chỉ có hai giá trị thôi. Tức là
gì? Tức là với năm cục còn lại chúng ta
có đủ các kiểu luôn đúng không? Chúng ta
có cả nominal, có cả original và có cả
ờ bine nữa đúng không? Chúng ta có đủ ba
kiểu thì bây giờ lõi chúng ta sẽ xử lý
cả ba kiểu này. Được chưa?
Thế thì bây giờ ấy xử lý với những kiểu
này thì cái kiểu
dễ hơn thì chúng ta sẽ làm cái gì dễ cho
làm trước đi ví dụ là cái raceity này
đúng không? Cái cột vế liên quan đến
chủng tộc được chưa? Ricity này. Cái cột
này nếu bây giờ tiền xử lý tức là gì?
Chúng ta sẽ đưa nó về trong trường chúng
ta đưa nó về dạng số đúng không? Đưa nó
về dạng số. Nào thì bây giờ với cái cột
này chúng ta đưa về dạng số thì chúng ta
đưa về kiểu gì các bạn? Đưa nó về cái
gì? Bây giờ
cái code chủng tộc này group A B C D E
này đưa về đạo số là đưa kiểu gì bây
giờ?
Đectơ đúng rồi. Cụ thể là vecơ gì nhỉ?
Cụ thể là vecơ gì?
Đúng rồi. One hot đúng không? Không phải
là không dùng oneh hot đúng không? Cái
này mà vectơm ing thì thì nó không mấy
đâu. Tại vì là
em ing nào bây giờ nó có phải là những
cái từ có nghĩa giống kiểu là các bạn
dùng những mình word to verb ở đâu đúng
không? Nó nó có phải là những cái từ
nhiên mà các bạn dùng được word to đâu
đúng không? Đây là dùng one hot thôi
đúng không? Oneh hot này nó cũng không
có không có quá nhiều giá trị mà năm giá
trị thôi. Unhot đúng không? A thì sẽ là
100,
B là 0100 vân vân vân vân đúng không?
Đấy. Bây giờ dùng unhot. Unhot thì cũng
dễ thôi. Trong se nó cũng có hot đây.
Đây one hot cái gì cũng có sẵn luôn.
Sách lọ điều rất là dễ rồi. Unhot này.
Fit ler này. Được chưa? Unhot đây.
Rất là dễ. Ờ các bạn dùng này như các
bạn chả phải chỉ ra cái gì các bạn cứ
dùng mặc định hết thôi. Đây onhot nhá.
Sc nó nó nó cũng nằm trong cái packet p
processing giống kiểu giống kiểu cái
standard scaler ấy nó đây nhá đúng không
cũng trong trong cái ping này được chưa
on hot nhá đây này đây
đây đ được chưa bây giờ nhá mình sẽ tạo
ra một cái mới cái này thì không phải là
no transformer nữa mình tạo ra một cái
khác này gọi là norm transformer
norm transformer được chưa input thì vẫn
đây nhưng mà đây không phải median đây
sẽ là most frequent được chưa đây nó
không Không phải scaler mà đây là
encoder. Được chưa? Đây mình dùng onhot
nhá.
Encoder thế này được chưa? Bây giờ mình
sẽ
mình cũng chạy mình cũng chạy thử nó
chạy thử nhưng mà output đây không phải
cột này nữa mà tôi sẽ dùng cái cột là
cột à
gì nhở? Race
e
ethnic city đúng không? Mình in thử cái
output ra nhá.
Print này. Output nhá. Pin cho nó dễ chị
đỡ phải ngồi đấy nhá. Output này nhìn
thử nhá.
À chết chết chết chết chết nhầm nom
former đây. Nom trer cái này mới đúng.
Mã vẫn gọi nhầm dùng trong cái cũ này
các bạn nhìn này. Các bạn nhìn kết quả
này.
Sao on hot nhìn lại các bạn nhỉ?
Bạn nào thấy mình ý nghĩa của của chỗ
này? On gì nhìn nhìn lại ấy nhỉ? On ví
dụi là 1 là 01 chứ đúng không? Sao on
thì nhìn lạ ấy nhỉ? Trông chả giống vecơ
gì cả.
Ai thấy mình cái cái này nó có ý nghĩa
gì?
Có ý nghĩa gì?
Nghĩa gì đấy? Nhìn chả giống onot gì cả.
Nhìn không được on hot đúng không? Nó
là cái gì đây? Đây không phải on hot thì
nó là cái gì đây?
Có giấy được không? Cái này có ý nghĩa
gì?
Cái kiểu viết này nó là cái kiểu viết
thích nghiệm tài nguyên. Tức là gì? Với
onh ấy các bạn biết là về onhot ấy là
hầu hết các cái giá trị đều bằng 0 đúng
không? Rất ít giá trị bằng 1. Thế ở đây
nó chỉ ra những cái chỗ nào nó khác một
à nó khác 0 thôi. Đây các bạn nhìn này.
Đây là coordinate đúng không? Chỉ số
hàng, chỉ số cột này đúng không? Tức là
gì? Với câu đầu tiên nó là hàng 0 đúng
không? Cái hàng 0 này ấ thì nó có giá
trị phần tương ứng là 2 nó là khác 0 nó
bằng 1 đúng không? Cụ thể bằng 1 này t
gì nó sẽ tương đương với gì là 0100 đấy
nó là group C đấy đúng không? Tiếp này
các bạn nh không cứ tăng 1 này
vì chỉ số hàng tăng 1 mà đúng không? Cứ
tăng 1 tăng 1 này đúng không? 1 3 thì là
00 10 đúng không? 22 này đây các bạn
không mỗi một hàng nó chỉ có một giá trị
thôi đúng không? Đây kiểu viết đây này.
Thay vì là tôi
ví dụ đây nhá. Đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn
có hai ông đầu đi vậy là ví dụ bình
thường là 0 1 này 0
10 đúng không? Viết này thì nó tốn tại
nguyên quá thì sẽ viết là gì? Phần tử vị
trí hàng 0 cột 2 đúng không? Cụ thể giá
trị là 1.0
hàng 1 cột 3 giá trị cụ thể là 1.0 tại
vì có thể trường hợp khác nó có giá trị
khác cơ đúng không? Thế kiểu này thì tôi
chỉ viết cái chỗ nào nó khác 0 thôi. Chỗ
khác 0 tọa độ là ở đâu? giá trị nó bằng
mấy còn chỗ khác tôi không chỉ ra là coi
như nó bằng 0 đúng thì đây kiểu viết này
kiểu viết tiết kiệm tài nguyên viết để
các bạn chỉ tập trung vào chỗ nào nó
khác không thôi đúng không thế còn nếu
mà các bạn mà các bạn muốn nhìn kiểu như
bình thường ấy các bạn muốn nhìn theo
kiểu là onh
ờ truyền thống như bình thường á thì đây
các bạn nhìn đây nó sẽ có một cái tham
số nó tên là cái cái spass output này
đúng không mà lệnh nó bằng true các bạn
đưa nó về phone thì nó sẽ thành kiểu
bình thường thôi. Đây cho bạn xem nhá.
Được chưa? Này thì bây giờ chạy lại đây
nó sẽ bình thường ngay. Được chưa?
Thì các bạn nhìn thấy đây đúng không?
Kiểu bình thường thô này. Được chưa?
Đấy.
Hai kiểu này sai cái lều hiểu. Hai kiểu
này m mô hình các bạn nó đều hiểu, nó
tương đương nhau chẳng khác gì. Nó chỉ
khác nhau là cho con người nhìn thôi.
Đúng không? Các bạn thích nhìn kiểu nào
hơn thôi chứ còn hai kiểu nó chả khác gì
nhau cả. Hai kiểu đưa vào mô hình nó
hiểu cả hai. Được chưa? Đây là các bạn
làm việc với cái giá trị dạng
à các cái feature dạng nominal đúng
không? Nominal tức là các cái giá trị đó
hoàn toàn nó bình đẳng nhau mặt bằng ý
nghĩa thì tôi dùng one hot đúng không?
Nó sẽ năm cái giá trị khác nhau. Tôi sẽ
dùng vectơ có năm phần tử thế này. Được
chưa?
Rồi ok đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì
không?
Có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Nếu không ai có thắc mắc gì chúng ta
nghỉ ra 5 phút nhá. 5 phút này bạn nào
các bạn muốn hỏi gì các bạn cứ hỏi nhá.
Mình vẫn ngồi chiếc máy thôi nhá.
Khi mình on hot anh quing nếu tập trang
bị thiếu một số value với tập test thì
lúc mà mình test ấy nó sẽ bị lỗi nhá.
Nếu hot ví dụ đây các bạn có chỉ có a
cde thôi trong quá trình test ấy mà các
bạn có một cái phần tử mới cái giá trị
mới ví dụ là F đi thì mặc định nếu các
bạn không can thiệp nó sẽ bị lỗi. Can
thiệp bằng cách nào? Can thiệp có nhiều
cách nhưng cách phổ biến nhất là gì? Là
trong quá trình test ấy, trong quá trình
mà influence sau này ấy, đúng không? Nếu
có một cái giá trị lỗi ấy, cái cách xử
lý đơn giản nhất để tránh cho máy m mô
hình chạy nó không bị lỗi là gì? Là
người ta sẽ vé người ta sẽ mép cái giá
trị mới này với một cái vecơ toàn số 0.
Thế thôi. Được chưa? Một là nó mé với
một giá trị toàn số 0. Hai là nó sẽ
ờ hai là nó sẽ mép cái giá trị này sang
cái class sang cái class nào mà có nhiều
nhiều phần tử nhất. Đấy nó có một vài
cách như vậy. Được chưa
nhá? Ai muốn hỏi gì các bạn câu hỏi nhá.
Mình vẫn ngồi chếc máy thôi.
>> [hắng giọng]
>> Mac mini [âm nhạc]
Mac Studio
>> [âm nhạc][ca hát]
>> Mình dùng bản free thôi. Mình dùng bằng
community thôi. Bằng commodity là đủ
rồi. Nếu vậy có cách nào phân chia tập
truyên vậ Tết mà đảm bảo là tập truyên
không bị thiếu đu
có phân chia thì có nhưng nó sẽ có khả
năng là như này là có thể có những cái
giá trị ấ nó chỉ xuất hiện nó chỉ có một
record thôi. Ví dụ cái group có một cái
giá trị là group F chẳng hạn nó chế một
record thôi. Và có khả năng là khi một
nó chỉ có một record như vậy khó khăn
khi mà chia nó sẽ rơi hết vào nó chỉ rơi
luôn vào bộ test thì bộ trên nó sẽ không
có. Tức là trường hợp cá biệt nếu các
bạn có nếu mà các bạn có ít sample quá
thì dù chúng ta có áp dụng cách nó vẫn
không đảm bảo là ờ là luôn có phần tử
nằm cả bộ trên bộ test đúng không? Nếu
mà chỉ một sample thôi nó sẽ rơi vào một
trong hai bộ thôi. Đó
đâu mình cũng dùng bản free mà.
Mình dùng bản mình cũng dùng bản free mà
mình toàn dùng community thôi. Mình mình
chưa bao giờ up lên professional bao giờ
cả. Mà có gửi ý code mà có thể là đây
mình còn chưa bật AI. Bật AI nó còn nữa
cơ. Bật AI thì bật AI hình như là ừ bật
AI thì mình có thể dùng cái A Pro trong
30 ngày các thứ như mình cũng chả dùng.
Mình mà dùng AI thì thì mình có dùng
copilot hoặc là hoặc là mình mình mình
dùng close chứ mình cũng không mình cũng
không dùng cái AI tích hợp vào trong vào
trong này. Ừ bài hm free vẫn có mà có mà
có thể là cái lúc em cài em cài nó vào
để tí xong buổi này đi. Mình thử mình
thử cô rồi xem màn hình xem xem là xem
là sao bản free đây nó vẫn bản này mình
phần free mà trước giờ mình toàn dùng
free thôi à.
Bản mình còn bản cũ ấy bản mình bản mình
chắc là bản 2025 mình nghĩ nghĩ đây xem
nào. Bản mình đâu ấ nhở xem about
không? Mình còn đang dùng cái bản à mình
m mình mình còn đang dùng bản cũ hơn cơ.
Mình đang dùng bản cũ hơn 2016 mình mình
chưa có đ bản mới đâu
mà không phải không phải do của bản đâu.
Kể có đảm có có có tài bản hay không hay
cái auto completion này nó có từ lâu lắm
rồi. Nó có trước khi có lm cơ nó có từ
lâu lắm rồi.
Thấy không? 16 GB là nhiều ấy chứ. Chắc
là chắc là có cái vấn đề gì cài chắc là
làm sao đấy thôi chứ còn
không thể hôm nào thử mai mình thử thử
cô một tí xem 16 GB là là là thoải mái
rồi mà 16 GB là thoải mái rồi.
Gì thế này
ra?
Thôi gì đây?
Thôi tiếp tiếp đủ rồi.
Rồi thôi tiếp tiếp tiếp xem thế đủ rồi.
Đâu ấy nhỉ?
Rồi tiếp nhá. Thấy chưa? Thì chúng ta xử
lý được à
chúng ta xử lý được à hai loại rồi. Một
là numerical feature
và hai là nominal feature. Bây còn lại
thứ ba nữa là ordinal feature đúng
không? Ordinal feature.
Ordinal hay một cái tên thôi.
Về ấy về mặt bản chất nó cũng là
categorical nên là cái bước đầu tiên nó
có thể t giống đúng không? Bước thứ hai
nó sẽ khác.
Bước thứ hai chúng ta sẽ không dùng
onhot đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ không dùng
onhot. Chúng ta sẽ dùng cái gì? Dùng cái
người ta gọi là ordinal encoder. Các bạn
chú ý này. Trong cái bộ rượu của chúng
ta ấy, chúng ta có đâu ấy nhỉ?
Chúng ta có có đây
đây đúng không? Đây là cái cột
categorical đây đúng không? À x cái cột
cột ordinal cái cột ordinal này thì à
thì à thì chúng ta có sáu giá trị này.
Thì bây giờ ấy cách mã hóa này rất là
đơn giản thôi. Chúng ta mã hóa chúng là
dụ từ 0 đến 5 đúng không? Có sáu giá trị
mà
mã hóa từ 0 đến 5 rất là dễ đúng không?
Thế bây giờ ấy nhưng mà với cái ấy có
một cái điều như thế này. Chúng ta sẽ
phải chỉ ra cái thứ tự mà chúng ta muốn
mã hóa. Tức là gì? Ví dụ như là some
high school. High school ờ ờ college
some college đúng không? Associate
degree này, ba degree này, master degree
đúng không? Chúng ta phải chỉ ra cái thứ
tự. Tại vì sao? Tại vì máy
ự luận ra cái thứ tự được đúng không?
Chúng ta là con người, chúng ta nhìn vào
chúng ta biết là gì? À hai spoon nó thấp
hơn bao, bao thấp hơn master đúng không?
Nhưng mà máy nó đâu có biết đâu. Máy nó
không biết cái điều đấy đúng không? Máy
nó không biết cái điều là ông nào thấp
vân ông nào là cao ông nào. Nên chúng ta
sẽ phải định nghĩa cái thứ tự vào. Được
chưa?
thứ tự ở đây
mình chút
nhá. Thế bây giờ mình phải đầu tiên mình
có cái dòng định nghĩa thứ tự đã. Ví dụ
là gì? Mình nghĩ là education
level nhá. Được chưa? Vậy có bạn nào có
bạn định nghĩa rồi mình copy phát nhở.
Đâu rồi? Vâ trên có bạn nào định nghĩa
đâu rồi nhỉ? Đây rồi. High school nhá.
1 này,
high school này
không gửi à
trong college này đúng không?
Cái gì đây? Associate degree này. Degre
được chưa?
Đấ dấu phẩy
bachelor degree này
và master degree này.
Được chưa? Thứ tự này đúng không? Thì
bây giờ ấy mình sẽ mình sẽ mình sẽ sử
dụng một cái class tên là đây là onhot
encoder đúng không? Mình sẽ có một cái
nữa gọi là đây này. Ngay cạnh nó này.
Ordinal encoder. Với cái encoder này
chúng ta sẽ phải chỉ ra cái thứ tự mà
chúng ta muốn encode. Các bạn dù nhìn
nhá. nó có một cái tham số là
categories.
Cái cột ordinal encoder này ấy hay là
cột onhot vừa nãy ấy nó có thể được sử
dụng để có thể mã hóa cho nhiều cột cùng
một lúc. Được chưa? Ví dụ onhot các bạn
có hai cột cùng là kiểu on đều kiểu
nominal các bạn có thể dùng onhot cho
hai ông đúng không? Or encoder cũng thế.
Do là chúng ta có thể dùng nó để chúng
ta có mã hóa cho nhiều cột. Thế nên là
cái category này ấy nó sẽ là một cái
list nó sẽ là một cái list của những cái
giống như array hay nó khác là gì? Nó là
list của list thế thôi đúng không? Giống
array chính là list đúng không? Giống
mảng ấy chính là list. Tức là gì? Nếu
các bạn muốn dùng cái
ordinal encoder này ấy để mã hóa cho ba
cột thì các bạn sẽ cần phải có một cái
list có ba phần tử. Mỗi phần tử lại là
một cái list khác. Nó định nghĩa các cái
thứ tự của các cái giá trị bên trong cái
cột tương ứng đúng không? Ví dụ bây giờ
các bạn có ba cột đi, mỗi một cột các
bạn có năm cái loại khác nhau đúng
không? Thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ phải chỉ
ra cái thứ tự của từng loại một đúng
không? Thì bây giờ trong trường hợp mình
thì mình chỉ có muốn dùng nó để mạ hóa
một cột thôi. Thế nên là cái K này nó sẽ
là một cái list của list. Và cái list
bên trong ấy nó sẽ có thứ tự của sáu cái
âm của mình. Được chưa? Đây này. Đúng
không? List chú ý nhá. Nó là list của
những cái thứ giống như là array. Mà
giống như array thì nó chính là list
đúng không? List của list đấy. Được
chưa? Đây này. Đúng không? Category I nó
sẽ giữ các cái giá trị của cái cột đấy
mà theo thứ tự. Được chưa? Thì bây giờ
mình vừa định nghĩ ở trên rồi đúng
không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ dùng đâu rồi?
Đây nhá. Bước thứ hai. Bước này là gì?
Là querer. Mình sẽ không dùng onhot đúng
không? Unhot không dùng được. Đấy. Dùng
là à mình chưa import. Quên mất chưa
import. Đây
anorder thế này được chưa? Order cho vào
đây nhá.
Mình sẽ phải chỉ ra cái thứ tự. Nếu các
bạn không chỉ ra thứ tự ấy là nó sẽ xếp
theo alpha B. Alpha B tên nó sẽ đây. A
này đây đúng không? Ông này sẽ là 0 ông
này sẽ là 1 này. Nó sắp thất alpha bề
kiểu gì cũng sai. Được chưa? Nó sắp thất
alpha B kiểu gì cũng sai. Được chưa?
Mình phải chỉ ra cái thứ tự của mình
đúng không? Đây bạn nhìn on quer mình sẽ
chỉ ra nhá. Category này đúng không?
Categories bằng cái gì? Bằng cái list
này. Được chưa? Trong cái list này mình
cho nguyên cái list bên trong vào nữa
này. Education được chưa? Đây mình chỉ
một cột thôi. Mình có một cái list này.
Nhiều cột sẽ có nhiều list hơn. Được
chưa? Bây mình sẽ dùng này mình dùng thử
vào đây
đây đúng không? Cho cột là cái gì nhở?
Level ofation đúng không? Bây giờ mình
sẽ in ngang hàng với nhau song hành
nhau. Tức là gì? Mình sẽ in before after
đúng không? For e
in zip này. Zip cái gì? Zip cái output
này với cả cái
đúng không? Cái này đi trước đi.
In thử nhá. Con em vẫn cho này.
Chết nó bị à
đây các bạn nhìn nhá. Đây này. Đúng
không? Có phải là
high school thì là 0 đúng không? Này S
high school thì là 0 này. Được chưa? Đây
này. Sig đây này. S high school thì là 0
đúng không? High school thì là 1 này.
High school thì là 1 này. Được chưa? S
college thì là 2.
Dig là 3. B là 4. Đúng master thì là 5
này. Được chưa? Đấy. Đây cách chúng ta
mã hóa nó. Nếu mà các bạn không chỉ ra
cái K này ấ nó sẽ theo nó sẽ xét alpha B
ngay. Đây nhá. Mình bỏ qua này đúng
không? Mình nhìn này. Theo alpha B này
thì ông nào cứ chữ A ở đầu này associate
này 0 này. Bio b là 1 này. Kiểu gì nó
cũng sai đúng không? Nếu các bạn không
tự chỉ ra kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ tự làm sai
đúng không? Đấy alpha B thì gần như là
kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ sai. Được chưa?
Thế thôi. Chúng ta đã xử lý được cái gì
rồi? No transformer rồi. Norm
transformer rồi đúng không? Và cả
transformer nữa đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ
dượng dữ liệu dạng numerical feature
rồi.
Categorical feature chúng ta sẽ có
nominal ordinal rồi đúng không?
Chúng ta còn thiếu cái gì nhỉ? Chúng ta
còn thiếu mấy ông bullin nữa đúng không?
Bụ này chúng ta có ba cột là cột bulin
đúng không? Ba cột cột bulin cho nhìn
qua một tí này.
Đây bulin là thứ nhất là chúng ta có cái
ừ gender là một này đúng không? Race à
không gender này. Lunch này với cả test
preparation cost đúng không? cho có ba
cột như này.
Thế bây gi các bạn nhìn này, với mấy cái
buling à từ trước khi đấy những cái phần
này có bác nào có câu hỏi gì không? Đã
có câu hỏi gì không? Có cái gì chưa
clear không các bạn? Mình có đi nhanh
quá không? Có cái gì chưa clear? Các bạn
cứ hỏi thoải mái nhá.
Nh tiếp này. Bây giờ mình còn ba cột
bulin chưa xử lý đúng không?
Ba cột buling này ấ bây giờ nếu mà muốn
xử lý chúng ta hoàn toàn chúng ta có thể
dễ dàng chúng ta lại tạo ra một cái
transformer mới đúng không? Chúng ta lại
tạo ra một cái transformer mới đúng
không? Đây mình có no với k ordin rồi
mình tạo ra một cái bing transformer
hoàn toàn thoải mái đúng không? Nhưng mà
bây giờ
nếu mà tạo ra một cái mới vậy thì tên
lại tốn thêm chỗ đúng không? Trong khi
chúng ta thật ra chúng ta có thể chúng
ta tận dụng những cái thứ đang có sẵn
đúng không? chúng ta sẽ không dùng được
no transformer tại vì no transformer nó
chỉ là dạng số thôi. Nó chỉ vị số thôi.
Của mình là ví dụ là gender là male và
female chẳng hạn thì chúng ta không có
dùng được. Tương tự với những cột kia
đúng không? Nom transformer thì không
dùng được nhưng mà norm transformer với
cả transformer thì lại dùng được. Hai
ông này về mặt kỹ thuật ấy nhá. Hai ông
này về mặt kỹ thuật cả Nor Transformer
và cả original transformer. Hai ông này
về mặt kỹ thuật đều có thể được dùng để
có thể xử lý cho dữ liệu dạng bulin. Hai
ông đều dùng được và đều đúng. Thế nhưng
mà thật ra trong hai ông này sẽ có một
ông dùng nó sẽ hơi tốt hơn một chút so
với ông còn lại. Theo các bạn là bây giờ
để mã hóa dữ liệu dạng bullin thì theo
các bạn dùng nominal non transformer
theo các bạn nó sẽ tối ưu hơn hay là
audio transformer nó sẽ tối ưu hơn? Và
lý do là vì sao?
Theo các bạn dùng cái nào tối ưu hơn?
Bạn lý do sao?
Nào hai ông dùng đều đúng. Nomor
transform farmer cũng dùng để mã hóa bin
được mà trer cũng được nhưng mà sẽ có
một ông tối hơn. Ông nào? Lý do làm vì
sao?
Ordin về việc hoàn thành về việc hoàn
thành cost có vẻ ok hơn là chưa? Tức là
sao nhỉ? Ordinal vì việc hoàn thành cost
có vẻ ok hơn là
tức là sao nhỉ? Chưa hiểu là non có vẻ
tối ưu hơn nào. Nominal transformer và
transformer cái nào tốt hơn lý do là vì
sao?
Ý là giống kiểu nếu đã học
thì sẽ tốt hơn học sau
rồi. Ok. Có bạn nào có có bác nào có có
có cách thể hích nào nữa không?
Nào theo các bạn nominal transformer và
original transformer hai ông dùng thì
đều đúng cả nhưng mà sẽ có âm tốt hơn
ông tối ưu hơn thì chính xác hơn cái nào
tối ưu hơn lý do là vì sao à chính xác
Phạm Tiến Đạt thô bạn Tiến Đạt này nó
nói đúng rồi hai cái chung đều được
nhưng mà dùng order nó sẽ tối hơn một
chút. Tại vì sao nếu các bạn dùng
nominal các bạn dùng on ấy nó sẽ tạo
thành một cột nữa đúng không? Tức là gì?
10 hoặc là 01 ta các bạn tốn hai cột.
Trong khi các bạn dùng original
transformer nó chỉ là một cột thôi, nó
chỉ là 0 hoặc là 0 hoặc là 1 thôi đúng
không? Hai ông dùng đều đúng nhưng mà
dùng original nó sẽ tiết kiệm tài nguyên
hơn
tài nguyên hơn đúng không? Tận dụng luôn
đây. Không ông này vậy tôi dùng thì tôi
sử dụng hôm nay bây giờ tôi sẽ sử tiếp
đúng không? Thì bây giờ muốn dùng tiếp
cho ba cái ba cái cột buling thì các bạn
phải chỉ ra cái thứ tự. Thế nhưng mà ví
dụ nhá ví dụ như là gender đúng không?
Các bạn có thể chỉ ra như này. Ok male
hoặc là female đúng không? Nhưng mà ấy
thật ra
với bullin á thì thứ tự nào cũng được,
mail đi trước cũng được, female đi trước
cũng được đúng không? Thì với bullin thì
kiểu gì cũng được các bạn không cần, các
bạn không chỉ ra cũng chả làm sao cả.
Thì bây giờ để cho dễ thì tôi sẽ có thể
làm này. Data exchange đúng không?
Exchange gender này. Tôi dùng cái gọi là
unic
này nó sẽ chỉ giá trị các bạn nhìn nhá.
Gender này chữ S đúng không? S này
đây nhá. Mình cho bạn xem thử nhá.
Render này nếu mà mình dùng cái unic nó
chỉ ra những cái giá trị khác biệt thôi
là tự nó lắm th nhỉ
đây chạy lại nhá
đây này chỉ có mail và female thôi được
chưa đấy tôi đâu có làm thứ tự đâu miễn
là có được đúng không thì tôi làm tương
tự như vậy thôi à lunch nhá
lunch này lun s hay đây nhỉ is đúng
không
này được chưa
Testation cost nà.
Test F đúng không?
Test
cái gì ấy nhỉ?
Viết liền này nó viết liền này nhở quen
à viết vết cách này test
cost đúng không? Sau đây bây gi mình sẽ
xử lý thôi.
Bây giờ mình dùng bốn này thì bây giờ
mình cũng phải đưa về đúng bốn cái này
đúng không?
Không lunch
cost này được chưa? Cho vào đây mà cho
đúng thứ tự luôn đúng không? Ông trên
thứ tự nào ông dưới thứ tự y chang như
thế được chưa?
Gender
lunchation
cross được chưa nhá. Đây là mình lúc các
bạn học thì các bạn tự code này cho nó
quen. Còn sau này các bạn đấy các bạn
dùng AI các bạn bật AI lên nó complete
cho các bạn hết mà nhá. Được chưa?
Bây giờ sẽ in mình sẽ in theo đúng cái
cả cụm luôn. In cả cụm luôn nhá. Bên
trong này nhá.
Đây mình in lúc trước v lúc sau nhá.
Trước v sau này chạy thử nhá.
Đấy thôi.
Đấy high school này ma thứ này đúng
không? H school thì nó về nó một này
đúng chưa? Thế thôi. Thế thì mình đã xử
lý xong được cả mấy cột nhỉ? Bảy cột rồi
đúng không? Bảy cột xử xong hết rồi.
Được chưa? Cái no transformer dùng xử xử
lý hai cột đọc với cả viết đúng không?
Cái norm transformer dùng để xử lý mỗi
cái cột liên quan đến cái mấy cái chủng
độc đúng không? Group AB CD đấy đúng
không? Và cái transformer dù phải sử nốt
những cột còn lại bao gồm là một cột
ordinal với cả ba cột bulling. Thôi được
chưa?
Thế bây giờ các bạn nhìn này. Đến đây có
ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Đến đây có ai có câu hỏi gì không?
Thế bây giác các bạn nhìn nhá. Thế bây
giờ nhìn này. Thế bây giờ chúng ta đang
ở cái chỗ nào rồi? chúng ta ở chỗ này
đây nhá. Có phải là bây giờ dữ liệu của
mình ấy cái data mình như này nhá. Data
mình như này này. Data mình ở đây này. Đ
mình như này. Đấy nó dài như này. Được
chưa? Đây ta mình tách ra thành à mấy
phần đúng không? Mấy phần như thế này
đúng không? Một phần đầu tiên cho qua
cái
numerical transformer. Phần thứ hai cho
qua
ordinal transformer. Phần thứ ba cho qua
non transformer đúng không? Sau đó thì
chúng ta
sau khi xử lý xong rồi chúng ta sẽ phải
làm gì? Chúng ta sẽ phải ghép lại vào
với nhau đúng không? Chúng ta sẽ phải
ghép chúng lại vào với nhau như này.
Ghép lại đây. Đây cho này cho vào đây
đúng không? Chỗ này cho vào đây. Chúng
cho vào đây đúng không? Ghép xong rồi
tĩa mình cho qua mô hình ví dụ đây model
mình ở dưới này. Moder cho dưới này luôn
cho qua sau đúng không? Thì bây giờ ấy
đúng không? Tất nhiên bây giờ ghép này
có nhiều cách ghép lắm. Ghép các bạn có
thể ghép thủ công các bạn dùng 5 thôi.
Tạiì bản chất tất cả bạn nó đều là 5
array cả. Các bạn có thể ghép stack nó
vào với nhau đúng không? Thế nhưng mà
trong sân ấy họ ngấp cho chúng ta một
cái công cụ rất là thuận tiện để chúng
ta có thể chúng ta dễ dàng chúng ta tách
ra và chúng ta gộp vào các bạn không nó
bao gồm hai phần đúng không? Phần tách
ra là một phần gộp vào là hai đúng
không? Thì bây giờ thay vì phải ngồi gọi
thủ công, thay vì bây giờ các bạn phải
ngồi các bạn tách ra là gì? Bây giờ là
ông này thì xử lý hai cột, ông này xử lý
một cột, ông này xử lý bốn cột. Thay vì
các bạn phải làm thủ công như vậy thì
bây giờ tôi sẽ mình chỉ các bạn cách để
làm sao các bạn có thể gộp lại. Các bạn
dùng các bạn sẽ phải tự động tách nó ra
rồi tự động gộp nó vào. Thế thì trong sơ
nó lại có một cái hàm nữa. Nó lại không
phải một hàm một cái class nữa. Nó tên
là column
transformer.
Cái này nó sinh ra là để làm gì? để
chúng ta có thể apply áp dụng những cái
transformer vào các cái cột khác nhau.
Được chưa? Nói chung phép chúng ta là áp
dụng các cái phép biến các cái biến đổi
khác nhau trên các cái cụm các cái cột
khác nhau. Được chưa? Thì trong cái
transformer này nó chỉ quan trọng nhất
là gì? là cái tham số đầu tiên là
Transformer. Đây là cái nơi các bạn sẽ
chỉ ra là các bạn sẽ áp dụng cái gì vào
những cột nào. Nó ná như là Pipeline mà
nó sẽ phức t hơn một chút. Tại vì
Pipeline nó sẽ là một cái đây nó cũng là
một cái list của t nhưng mà nếu mà các
cái tip ấy nó chỉ có nó chỉ có hai giá
trị thôi là tên của cái bước đấy và cái
bước cụ thể là gì. Thế còn col transform
nó sẽ có ba cái. Một là tên của bước
đấy. Cái tên này thì nó cũng giống như
là cái tên ở đây thôi. Đều là name cả.
Được chưa? Nhưng mà cái thứ hai cái
transformer là các bạn dùng cái mô hình
gì và thứ ba là các bạn sẽ chỉ ra là các
bạn sẽ áp dụng nó lên cái cột nào được
chưa? Các bạn sẽ chỉ ra là các bạn muốn
áp dụng cái phép biến đổi này lên
những cái cột nào đúng không? Lên những
cái cột nào mình sẽ dùng thử cho bạn rất
là dễ thôi. Được chưa? Một cái toper à
một cái list của bao gồm những cái t này
nó bao gồm ba ông này. Thế là xong được
chưa? Dùng thử nhá. Dùng thử này rất là
dễ thôi. Secular.cos này
nhá.
formitle
learn.cose này được chưa? Transformer
được chưa? Thế bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ
không ngồi gõ thủ công như này nữa được
chưa? Gõ thủ công này. Bây giờ mình sẽ
sau khi mình khai báo xong ba cái
transformer này rồi bây gium
transformer. Mình sẽ gọi nó là một cái
bước này mình gọi là precessor
được chưa? Bằng column
không có hàm phải có hàm ý. Chắc chắn nó
phải có hàm. Chắc là em áp dụng vào nhầm
thứ rồi. Nó phải pandas nó phải có hàm.
Chắc là em áp dụng vào một cái gì đấy
khác rồi. Hoặc là em gõ sai rồi hoặc là
em thiếu ngoặc. Đấy chứ còn nó là pandas
kiểu gì nó chả phải có nhá. Thử nhìn kỹ
lại xem. Hoặc là em thử chụp ảnh em gửi
lên Zalo xem.
Được chưa? Đấy colum transform nhá. Bạn
nào các bạn có m lỗi gì các bạn cứ gửi
mình trên Zalo nhá. Mình xem cho
nhá. Colum transformer này. Transformer
nhá. Được chưa? Các bạn sẽ có một column
transformer
rồi như này. Được chưa? Các bạn sẽ có
một cái transformer ở đây. Cái list này
được chưa? Đ cái toer nhá. Được chưa?
Bắt đầu này. Được chưa? Các bạn nhìn
nhá. Bắt đầu gồm mỗi tu bao gồm thứ. Là
tên tên thì các bạn muốn điền cái gì
cũng được nhưng mà điền cái gì sau này
các bạn nhìn vào cho nó dễ. Ví dụ mình
sẽ đặt tên là no picture chưa? Tên cái
gì cũng được. Sau đó là cái bước thứ hai
là gì? Là các bạn sẽ chỉ ra là các bạn
sẽ áp dụng cái transformer nào? Cái phép
biến đổi gì? Mình sẽ dùng cái N
Transformer này này. Vừa đây kh này này.
Thấy thôi. Đúng không? Nome Transformer.
Nome
farmer. Đây mình bạn mi gửi rồi. Ờ mi
gửi rồi.
À cái của em tại vì em đang dùng hai
ngoặc. Em nhìn kỹ nhá. Nó chỉ có một cái
ngoặc thôi. Em dùng hai ngoặc nên nó bị
đấy nhá. Em em bỏ bớt ờ mi bỏ bớt một
cái ngoặc đi là xong đúng không? Hai
ngoặc nó sẽ lỗ đen chỉ dùng một ngặc tơn
cho anh này. Đấy là xong nhá. Nhá các
bạn tiếp nhá. Đúng không? Tôi tôi cái
tên này tên gì cũng được. Nhìn cho nó
sao đặt sao cho nó gợi nhớ để tí nữa
mình còn dùng green search. Tĩ mình dùng
green search mình dựa vào cái tên này
đúng không? Áp dụng vào đâu và các bạn
sẽ phải chỉ ra các bạn áp dụng nó lên
cái cột nào đúng không? Cái này thì cái
này nó gọi là cái này đâu rồi?
Đây column column đây nhá. Colum này
bằng cái gì? Mình sẽ áp dụng nó lên hai
cột. Cột đầu tiên là
cột đầu tiên là à heading score đúng
không? Cột thứ hai là writing score này.
Được chưa? Một cái này được chưa? Cái
thứ hai. Cái thứ hai bây giờ mình sẽ gọi
là gì?
Cái thứ hai là gì? Cái norm nom norm
feature đi. Được chưa?
Nature
được chưa? Kể cả nó chỉ có một thôi.
Mình cứ ghi tổng quát mình cứ ghi số
nhiều nhá. Nhưng mà thật ra nó trong nh
nó chỉ có một thôi. Nor transformer đúng
không? Cái này thì
mình sẽ chỉ áp dụng nó kể cả mình mình
chỉ có một mình cũng dùng cái list này
nhá. Mình sẽ áp dụng nom là vào đâu nhở?
Vào cái
raceity đúng không? Race
được chưa?
Hai rồi được chưa? Cuối cùng này cuối
cùng mình gọi là
ure đúng không? Hoặc mình gọi là được
chưa? Or tại vì nó bao gồm cả nó bao gồm
cả cả
bullin mà đúng không? Gọi là
transformer
sao nó không g ý nhở?
Được chưa? Mình sẽ ốp nó vào bốn code.
Đây này. Bốn con code. Vẫn mình gõ mình
gõ tên ở trên này này. Được chưa? Cây
nhá. Đấy.
Thế thôi đúng không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
bây giờ mình sẽ
đây là đây là con transformer đúng
không? Tức là gì? Mình chỉ ra là gì? Là
cái đầu tiên này nó dùng để xử lý hai
cột, xử lý một cột và xử lý bốn cột nữa
đúng không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ tr form
thôi nhá. Như mình ghi là output này
bằng free
processor
chấm fish andform nhá. Xe này được chưa?
Giờ bạn xem cái output châm như nào nhá.
Được chưa? Output châm như nào? Nhìn
này.
Output đây này. Các bạn nhìn chưa?
Output này lúc ban đầu chúng ta có bảy
cột nhưng mà output nó có 11 cột. Tại vì
sao? Nhìn thử qua một tí nhá. Tại vì sao
11? Tại vì reading nó vẫn chỉ là một cột
thôi. Cột reading cột đầu này. Writing
là cột thứ hai. Được chưa? Race SD chủng
hợp này nó sẽ là năm cột tiếp này. 1 2
tại vì nó on hot mà đúng không? On hot
mà đúng không? 00
10 on hot đúng không? Từ 2 đến 6 là cho
cột chủng tộc này đúng không? Ờ 7 8 9 10
thì là đây 7 8 9 10 mà cái dưới này đây
7 8 9 10 được chưa? 9 10 đây.
Được chưa? Đấy thì đấy là lý do vì sao
lúc đầu có bảy cột đúng không? Nhưng mà
riêng cột chủng tộc này bây giẻ từ 1 đến
5 cột rồi nên các bạn cần gọi là thêm
bốn cột mới là các bạn có 11 cột đúng
không? Đấy
thấy chưa? Các bạn dùng cái các bạn dùng
cái colum transformer này các bạn có thể
chỉ ra là gì? Tôi sẽ dùng tôi sẽ áp dụng
cái phép biến đuổi nào lên những cột gì.
Được chưa? Rất là dễ.
Rồi đến đây đúng không? Việc mình gọi là
exchange đúng không? Exchange này đến
đây chúng ta làm cái gì nữa các bạn?
Tiền xử lý xong rồi chúng ta làm cái gì
tiếp bây giờ?
Sau khi tiền xử lý xong mình làm cái gì
Chúng ta chọn model đúng không? Chọn
model sau đó ghép nó vào với nhau đúng
không? Moder thì như vậy như mình nói từ
đầu thôi, mình sẽ chọn mình tuyến tính.
Tại vì là mình trong này mình thấy có
hai ít nhất là có hai cột điểm đọc điểm
viết cái hệ số tương quan lớn với tit
đúng không? Chọn mô hình tuyến tính. Đây
là bài toán hồi Q thì mình chọn mô hình
tuyến tính là mô hình linear rear
reaction này đây.
Form secit learn.linear model linear
question đúng không? Và các bạn nhìn bây
gi
bây giờ bâ bây giờ mình mình lại dùng
pipeline một lần nữa mình lại gộp chúng
vào với nhau đúng không? Vẫn mình dùng
pipeline ở trên rồi bây giờ
nhá. Có phải là bây giờ model bằng
apply đúng không? Step như này đúng
không? Không phải bước đầu tiên chính là
cái bước mà quy đấy đúng không? Bước đầu
tiên đây. Bước thứ hai đây mình mình gọi
là ừ này cũng được. Được chưa? Đấy tức
là gì? Ở trên dùng pip một lần rồi dưới
lại dùng pip một lần nữa đâ để tránh
phải gọi nhiều lần đúng không? Tránh
phải fit trong form này xong lại fit tr
form này đúng không? Thế thì bây giờ
mình chuyên thôi. Model mom.fit này. Thế
thôi xong bước này thì là xong rồi. Về
mặt huấn luyện thì là xong rồi chưa?
Đấy, tất nhiên là nó chưa in ra cái gì
tại vì chúng ta đã làm cái gì đâu đúng
không? Chúng ta không phải chúng ta có
in ra cái gì đâu đúng không? Muốn in ra
cái gì đấy thì bây giờ mình phải ví dụ
bây giờ mình đem mô hình đi dự đoán nhá.
Đúng không? Bây giờ Idex đúng không?
Bằng moder xest đâ này. Được chưa? Chơi
một xíu này.
Cho mình một xíu nhá.
Cho mình nhá.
Rồi các bác nhìn nhá.
Sao mà sao sao biết được level of
education? Tại vì là ở trên mình truyền
vào rồi mà đúng không? Ở trên này này
mình mình truyền vào này education level
đây này đúng không? Mình đưa nó vào đây
rồi đúng không? Thì nó sẽ mạ hóa gì đây
này? 0 này, 1 này, 2 này, 3 này, 4 này,
5 này đúng không? Thì mình mình chỉ ra
do mình chỉ ra cái thứ tự này nên là lúc
nó ma hoa nó sẽ ma hoa đúng cái thứ tự
của mình đúng không? Nên mình cho các
bạn xem nó cái vân vẫy chạy đi nhá.
Đâu nhở? Với cái phần
đây ngựa đây nhá. Đại cho các bạn xem
nhá.
Đây ví dụ đây đúng không? Ví dụ này này
đây mình xem cái x ex xin nhá. Đây này
exchange đây. Đây này level nó chỗ nào
nhỉ? À đây này cột số 7 này đâ đây này
đây này. Đấy level of education đấy. Đó
rồi bây giờ mình lại
đây bước này đúng không? Thì bây gián về
cái px cạnh nhau đúng không? E in zip
đúng không? Vest này print này đúng
không?
Đúng không?
Ex value
được chưa? Thầy thử nhá.
Đây
dựo là bên trái giá nó chị thật là bên
phải đúng không?
Nhìn sơ qua thì à
các bạn thấy thế nào nhỉ? Nhìn sơ qua dự
đoán các bạn các bạn thấy thế nào? Lệch
khoảng bao nhiêu nhỉ? Lệch khoảng à
4 năm gì đấy nhở?
4 5 sáu giá trị sáu đơn vị gì đấy đúng
không? A đúng không? Tất nhiên là bây
giờ mình muốn biết nó tốt hay không thì
mình cứ phải in magic ra đã đúng không?
Chứ nhìn chay này cũng hơi khó đúng
không? Nhìn qua thì
ừ lấy khoảng 4 năm gì đây đúng không?
Thế bây giờ mình thử in ra nhá. Đúng
không? Magic thì có rất là nhiều đúng
không các bạn? Nhớ là với bài toán hôm
nọ là chúng ta nói về những cái magic
dành cho bài toán a classification đúng
không? Chúng hôm nay chúng nói về magic
dành cho bài toán reaction đây. Hôm nọ
classification đây đúng không? Acura
vision rec one auc rủ các thứ cả đúng
không? Confusion magic classification
report đủ hết cả đúng không? Đấy thế bây
giờ mình xem về bài toán reaction thì
sao? Reaction thì mình sẽ có là mean
absolute này. Min square này đúng không?
Min square mà khai căn thì sẽ là root
min square đây. Root min square đây này.
Root min square này hoặc là
coefficient of determination đúng không?
Cái này mình học rồi đúng không? Hôm
chúng ta học về các cái magic đấy đúng
không? Đấy thì chúng ta dùng cả đúng
không? Cách dùng nó cũng giống như là
dùng cho các cái magic của bài toán
classification thôi các bạn. Bao giờ các
bạn cũng đưa về y dự y thực tế trước y
dự đoán sau đúng không? Nhưng mà nhớ này
là tùy các cái framew nó quy định nhá.
này bạn nào học tiếp lên khóa sau học
tiếp khóa về deep learning ấy nó lại
dùng ngược lại nó lại đưa vào i dự đoán
đi trước y thực tế vào sau đấy nhá nhưng
mà thôi mình đang dùng sơn thì dùng theo
thứ tự này được chưa bây gi phải import
đã import thì rất là nhiều đây mình
import ba cái đại đ đại ba cái đại diện
thôi đúng không form
learn chmmetrix này mean square này mean
absolute này đúng không và coefficient
of determination được chưa mình bây giờ
mình sẽ không in ra cả lố này nữa mình
sẽ in ra matrix thôi. Green nhá. Min
absolute đi trước này. Được chưa?
Min absolute er sao nhỉ? Được chưa? Min
square này.
Min square
square thiếu d đúng không? Coefficient
of determination này đúng không? H
square
được chưa? Đây là ba cái magic của mình
được chưa? Ma magic của mình này chạy
này. Được chưa?
Đây kết quả đây.
Các bạn thấy nào?
Các bạn thấy
nào?
Chưa tối ưu gì cả đúng không? Cứ chạy cứ
chạy chạy được cái đã đúng không?
Đấy nào? Minus min square
ừ cũng được đúng không? Cũng được đúng
không, 86 cũng không có tồi lắm nhỉ?
Đúng không? Coefficient of detion cũng
không có tồi lắm đúng không? Có b nào
giải thích mình là vì sao nhá? Nếu bình
thường theo mình hiểu đúng không?
Min áp suất là bậc 1, min square là bậc
2 đúng không? 4 bình phương phải khoảng
16 mà sau đây min square lên đến 28 này
đúng không? Bình thường đây là 4,2 bình
phương lên nó cũng khoảng 16 17 thôi.
Sau đây lên đến 28 này. Bậc 1 là 4, bậc
hai là 28. Sẽ có sự tr nó nó khác biệt
nhiều như vậy.
Sợ khác biệt nhiều như thế nhở.
Vì sao? Min á su có 4,2 min square lên
đến 28 đã nh này bình phương lên khoảng
16 thôi ch nhỉ lại lên 28 này
ngựa này
đúng rồi tổng tính của sai số nó khác
với bình phương của tổng sai số đúng rồi
tức là gì tức là nó có những cái sai số
nó lớn thế thôi đúng không có vẻ có vẻ
out không tôi không biết đúng là out nó
có thể nó nó out size số lớn thật nhưng
mà chỉ đơn giản là gì là mô hình có
nhiều những cái dự đoán đơn lẻ nó size
số lớn lớn thôi. X lớn thì bình phương
lên nó bị nó nhiều đúng không? Rồi thôi
đây là mình đang dùng một mô hình tuyến
tính đúng không? Mình bảo là theo lý
thuyết đúng không? Theo lý thuyết thì mô
hình tuyển nó tốt hơn đúng không? Thì
mình thử xem có đúng không nhá. Thì bây
giờ mình cứ copy mình past vào đây được
chưa? Đây là mô hình hồi quy của à đây
là mô hình linear reaction đúng không?
Thế bây giờ mình hãy thử và một bằng một
so sánh nó với một cái mô hình phi tuyến
đi. Ví dụ như là support better machine
đi đúng không? Đúng rồi. Mô hình đây.
Formit
learn. Assemble Random Fred này đúng
không? R mình sẽ mình sẽ thử nhá. Đâu
rồi? R mình thử thêm mô hình đây đúng
không? Random
này. Random state này bằng ví dụ đây
nhá. Mình fix một bườm một cái số đấy
chạy thử xem là điệu mình tốt hơn nhá.
Nào
linear reaction thì đây dưới này ông nào
tốt hơn các bạn? Ông nào tốt hơn?
Hai mô hình này mô hình nào tốt hơn?
Ng nào tốt hơn?
Ngôi nào tốt hơn? Cả hai đều là
regression cả. Cả hai đều là regression
đúng không? Linear đúng rồi. Mình linear
tốt hơn đúng không? Trong này thì lý
trong này lý thuyết đ nó đúng rồi đấy
đúng không? Này lý thuyết đúng đúng
không? Cho rõ ràng gì? Bộ rượu chúng ta
có những cái feature có hệ số tương quan
lớn với tit đúng không? Nên là tôi chọn
một hình tuyến tính nó sẽ tốt hơn đúng
không? Nó vừa nhẹ hơn, đơn giản hơn, dễ
giải thích hơn đúng không? quay ngược
lại giải động dễ hơn đúng không? Đấ
mà tất nhiên đây mới là chúng ta chạy mô
hình một lần. Tất nhiên chúng ta phải có
thể thử nhiều mô hình khác nữa. Thử
support better machine đúng không? Thử
nhá. Ờ formid
learn.sv
s.svm
import svr đúng không? R là cho
regression còn c là cho classifications
đúng không? Trong regression thì tôi sẽ
không có chọn này.
SVC. Tất nhiên SVC nó cũng là à SVR cũng
là một cũng là một mô hình phí tuyến
đúng không? Cũng là một mô hình phí
tuyến
đây đúng không? Nhìn chung là cũng không
tốt bằng đúng không? Đúng không? Mô hình
linear reation vẫn là tốt nhất đúng
không? Đấy thôi mình lại quay mô hình nà
tốt thì mình quay lại về mô hình đấy
thôi đúng không?
Chạy lại
chưa?
Bây giờ như một thói quen bây giờ tôi
lại cần đây là tôi chạy xong rồi đúng
không? Nhưng mà tất nhiên tôi còn phải
tối ưu nó nữa chứ có phải chạy một phát
là xong ngay đâu đúng không? Tối ưu thì
mình lại dùng green search đúng không?
Dùng green search ví dụ bài trước chúng
ta dùng resarch nào thì bài cho bạn cang
vào thôi. Nhưng mà các bạn chú ý này.
Bây giờ ấy để
research cho nó dễ thì mình sẽ chuyển
sang random forest. Tại vì sao? Random
forest nó có nhiều tham số, nó có nó có
nhiều siêu tham số thì green search làm
cho nó dễ. Còn mô hình linear các cái x
số nó nó ít lắm và nó khó để nó có thể
thay đổi lắm. Thế nên là bây giờ mình
biết là mô hình linear là mô hình tốt
nhất rồi nhưng mà bây giờ để cho phục vụ
cho cái việc f tool đúng không? Tìm ra
cái bộ s tối ưu thì bây giờ hãy coi như
là tôi dùng random for đi nhá. Không để
có nhiều nó có nhiều thứ để để tôi làm
việc hơn đúng không? Random forestion
này nhá. Sage này nhá. Được chưa? Thế
thế bây giờ cũng giống như bài kia thì
tôi cũng sẽ phải là gì? Tôi cũng sẽ phải
phải phải à
tôi cũng sẽ phải à đấy cũng phải đến cái
tham số này. Nhưng mà có có một điểm các
bạn chú ý này là gì? Tuy là cùng là
random for các bạn nhìn nhá.
Random forest nhá. Tuy ấ là cùng là R
for cả nhưng mà các bạn chú ý này. Đây
bên này R FR nhá.
Đây là
các bạn nhìn nhá. Bên trái là random
fres dành cho bài toán classification và
bên phải là cho bài toán reaction. Nhìn
chung thì các cái tham số của chúng tên
tuổi nó chả khác gì nhau cả. Đều là số
lượng cây này. Đ số lượng cây này đúng
không? Đều là criterian đều là criterian
này đúng không? Còn dưới đều là max step
các thứ giống như hiện nhau. Nhưng các
bạn chú ý này, tên của cái siêu âm số
thì nó không khác nhau nhá. Nhưng mà cái
giá trị cụ thể nó thì có những cái thứ
nó khác nhau. Ví dụ đây đây nó dùng gini
enp lop los này. Ông này lại dùng cái
gì? Square này, absur er này, fritman
mean square này, poison này. Được chưa?
Tức là gì? Tên của cái siêu âm số thì nó
không khác gì nhau nhưng mà cái giá trị
cụ thể nó lại khác nhau. Thế nên là khi
mà các bạn dùng khi mà các bạn dùng
green search ấ các bạn phải chú ý đúng
không? Các bạn chờ mình chút nhá
nhá.
Chờ mình một xí mình xí nhá. Đấy, tên
tên thì nó giống yền nhau nhưng mà cái
giá trị nó khác nhau thì là dùng sẽ dùng
resarch. Nếu mình dùng với mình dùng với
reaction thì phải chú ý tại vì nếu không
các bạn copy nguyên các cái giá trị của
bên classification ấy thì nó sẽ bị sai,
nó sẽ bị lệch, nó khác nhau. Được chưa?
Đấy, bây gi mình quay lại cái code của
mình này. Mình này nhá. Được chưa? Thế
bây giờ mình copy thì mình sẽ phải đổi
cái giá trị này đi. Xong parameter này
mình copy vào đây nhá. Copy sang bên
này. Được chưa? Mình à mình muốn dùng
green search đúng không? Dùng resarch
thì mình cho vào đây vào đây cái đã đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà mình sẽ phải đổi cái
giá trị này đi đúng không? Giá trị này
nó phải không phải của classification nó
lại của reaction cơ. Reaction nhìn này
đó mình có gì nhỉ? Các bạn có à square
er này đen gì đấy đúng không? Mình cho
vào đây cũng chả mình cũng không rõ lắm
đúng không? Có cái gì nhưng mà chắc là
một cái là bậc bậc hai, một cái bậc một
này đúng không?
Cái này chả biết là cái gì cho vào đúng
không? Cho vào thế đúng không? Đấy. Sau
đó mình sẽ áp dụng tương tự thôi. Này
green search này. Đây model các thứ này
đúng không? Model fit phủng các thứ này
cũng chả khác gì cả đúng không? Đây.
Đấy. Tôi bây giờ model của tôi nó sẽ
không còn là một ông này nữa mà model
của tôi sẽ như này.
Thì ở đây bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ không
gọi là như này. Mình sẽ gọi nó như nào
nhỉ? Mình sẽ gọi đây là
pipeline đi được không? Pipeline cho
mình nhét pip này vào dưới này.
Đấy pipeline này cái scoring cũng phải
đổi đi. Tại vì sao? F1 là score dành cho
bài toán. phân loại như đây lại không
phải phân loại, đây là hồi Q đúng không?
Đây là hồi Q.
Thế thì với hồi Q thì chúng ta lại phải
xem nó có những cái đấy hồi Q thì đây
chúng xem danh sách nó có những cái gì Q
trong đây các bạn nhìn nhá.
Lại xem nó có cái MC gì đúng không?
Chúng ta dùng cái tên của nó đây các bạn
nhìn này. À mình dùng cái a
đây có sẽ dùng cái swing name nhá. bình
thường ở đây đúng không? Tôi dùng cái
name dùng cái tên này cho nó dễ. Được
chưa? Các bạn nhìn nhá. Ờ với bài toán
hồi với bài toán hồi quy này các bạn sẽ
có ví dụ như cái min absorot thì đây các
bạn dùng cái tên này negative là dấu âm
đấy đúng không? Negative min upot này.
Negative min square root này đúng không?
Negative root min square root này đúng
không? Hoặc là a square này đúng không?
Đấy ví dụ mình dùng a square chẳng hạn.
Ví dụ như vậy đâ a square này. Được
chưa?
Mình hỏi các bạn một tí nhá. Hỏi thêm
này, các bạn có biết là vì sao những cái
magic của bài toán classification ví dụ
là accuracy này, F1 này, pr recol này
hoặc là hoặc là cái a square này ấy tên
nó bình thường. Thế nhưng mà mấy cái ông
mà min absur với min square nó lại có
cái chữ negative này không? Các bạn biết
là vì sao không?
Các bạn biết được vì sao lại có chữ
negative này không?
Các bạn biết làm vì sao có chữ negative
này không?
Không phải sai số không bao giờ âm. Min
áp suất nó đóng chi tuyệt đối mà trị đối
làm sao mà âm được. Min square là bình
phương bình phương làm sao mà âm được
đúng không? Làm sao mà âm được đúng
không? Đóng trị tuyệt đối không âm được
bình phương cũng không âm được. Đúng vì
sao có chữ negative này?
Có ai biết là vì sao lại có chữ negative
này không?
Các ông khác không có đúng không?
Coefficient of determination không có.
Aquacion reconnect one cũng không có.
Sao t ông này lòi ra này.
Đúng rồi. Cái sự khác biệt là gì? Đúng
rồi. Cái sự khác biệt chính xác. Đúng
rồi. Chính chính xác thì là đúng rồi.
Tức là gì? Acuracy record hay là a
square ấy nó đều có đặc điểm gì? nó càng
lớn thì càng tốt. Nhưng mà mấy ông này
nó lại là càng bé càng tốt. Thế nên
người ta đặt cái chữ negative để sao để
sau này tức là tôi tôi đưa hết về cùng
một cái tiêu chuẩn là gì? Là điểm càng
to càng tốt đúng không? Tôi đặt dấu trừ
lại thì nó sẽ chuyển đổi là từ bé đúng
không? Min áp suất min square mà nó từ
càng bé càng tốt. Tôi đặt dấu trừ vào nó
thành là càng lớn càng tốt để nó giống
với các cái matric còn lại đúng không?
Đấy như cái ông nào mà các bạn nhìn chữ
negative thì các bạn hiểu là tại vì cái
magic gốc ấy là càng bé nó càng tốt.
Được chưa? Đây mình dùng a square nhá.
Dùng a square như này được chưa? Thì thế
thôi đúng không? Chạy thử nhá. Bây mình
chạy thử này. Mod fit modeline các thứ.
Ok đúng không? Chạy thử này. Chạy thử
nhá. Tất nhiên mình ờ mình cũng muốn là
mình sẽ in ra cái gì nhỉ? Mình sẽ in ra
cái đây best score các thứ này. Được
chưa? Nhìn nhá. Nếu bây giờ mình cứ để
nguyên này mình chạy nhá. Nếu bây giờ
mình cứ để nguyên này mình chạy chạy thử
này
nó sẽ lỗi. Tại vì sao các bạn nhìn này
mình đang muốn nghi search cho những cái
ông tên như này được chưa? And estimator
là kitarian này. Được chưa? Nó như này.
Nhưng mà các bạn nhìn nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này, ở đây nó hiện một cái
một cái lỗi gì các bạn nhìn này. Lúc
trước ấy cái bài của lần trước ấy chúng
ta cái bài của cái bài của tấn trước ấy
chúng ta chúng ta green search là chúng
ta green search
chỉ cho cái mô hình của tôi thôi. Ví dụ
tôi chỉ resarch cho mô hình random fres
thôi. Thì cái mô hình này rõ ràng nó
đúng là nó có những có những cái siêu âm
số như này đúng không? Đây là những cái
siêu âm số của random fred thì không sao
không vấn đề gì. Nhưng mà hôm nay ấ cái
mà chúng ta green search ấy chúng ta
không chỉ green search cho mỗi cái mô
hình của chúng ta mà chúng ta đang green
search cho cả một cái pipeline. Được
chưa? Cái pipeline này ấy nó bao gồm
nhiều thành phần ví dụ đây nó bao gồm
hai thành phần đúng không? Và cái mô
hình chúng ta ấy nó chỉ là một trong số
những thành phần đó đúng không? Nên là
nếu các bạn đặt cái tên như này ấy thì
cái green search này nó sẽ không biết là
cái tên này là của ông nào. Nó là của
ông Ron Forest hay nó là của ông
preprocessor đúng không? Chúng ta là
người chúng ta nhìn chúng ta biết nhưng
mà máy nó đâu có biết cái điều đấy đúng
không? Nó không biết là carient nó rơi
vào đâu. Tại vì là đúng không? Có đây là
đây là nó bây gi nó là cảm cái pipeline
mà đúng không? Thì bây giờ các bạn phải
chỉ ra cụ thể là đây là cái tham số
thuộc về cái bước requester này. Được
chưa? Làm sao để làm được như vậy? Thì
cái cái quy ước của RF là gì? Là chúng
ta sẽ phải chỉ ra cái tên của cái bước
đấy. Sau các bạn phải có hai cái dấu
underscore hai cái dấu ga chân ở dưới
rồi các bạn đến tên của tham số của siêu
hm số. Ví dụ nhá nhìn này. Ví dụ đây
mình chỉ ra cái tên nhá. Mình sẽ không
đấy là tên này. Mình sẽ ghi là requester
này. Được chưa? Rồi hai dấu underscore
được chưa? Vì sao lại phải hai dấu? Tại
vì là có những cái tham số, có những cái
siêu âm số mà tên của nó đã có một dấu
rồi. Thế nên bây giờ mình chỉ có một dấu
thôi nó sẽ không phân biệt được hai ông
này với nhau đúng không? Nó phải có hai
ông như này chưa? Hai ông này như này.
Được chưa? Thế giờ mình cũng copy vào
đây
này. Được chưa? Đấy cứ hai cái dấu
undersore thì lôi chạy nó sẽ không bị
lỗi nữa. Còn không thì các bạn nhìn này
đúng không? Nó sẽ bị cái lỗi này. Nó
không biết là cái kia nó là cho cái gì
tại vì mình có cảm một cái pipeline cơ
mà đúng không? Đây mình chỉ ra cụ thể là
đây là hai cái xâm số của cái bước rever
này nhá.
chưa?
Đấy thôi lại win này. Thôi
chờ chạy một tí thôi. Mình chạy bao
nhiêu cây nhở? Chạy nhiều quá lâu.
Mình cho ít đi nhá. Cho nhanh nhá. Mình
cho nhiều quá chạy lâu lắm nhá. Ví dụ là
20 100 thôi. Rồi mình thử thử nhanh thôi
đúng không? Chạy nhanh đúng không? Khi
nào có nhiều ra mình thử nhiều hơn. Được
chưa?
Đây đúng không? Đấy chạy nhanh hơn đúng
không? Ít cây chạy nhanh mà đúng không?
Đây mình sẽ in thế này đúng không? Tất
nhiên cũng khi dùng resarch ấ các bạn
dùng xong là tự nhiên là nó sẽ auto nó
sẽ lưu lại cái option tốt nhất của các
bạn đúng không? có cái option tốt nhất ở
đây này. Tức là gì? Nó là option tốt
nhất là với square root này kết hợp với
100 cây được chưa? Đấy. Vậy mình nhớ là
cái option mặc định nó là 42 vì nó 40 nó
tốt hơn một chút xíu rồi. Đó. Thế thôi.
Đấy và các bạn chú ý nhá. Thế bây giờ
giả sử nhá đây là đây đây là tôi mới chỉ
file tool cho những cái phần của ông này
thôi đúng không? Bây giờ tôi muốn đi
show vào cái phần prester tôi file tool
làm sao? Ví dụ nhá. Ví dụ đi. Ví dụ bây
giờ tôi nó muốn xem là ví dụ là trong
cái imputer này median phải min cái nào
tốt hơn đúng. Tất nhiên trong bài này nó
chả khác gì nhau. Tại vì là bài này
chúng ta làm gì có dựa bị khuyết đâu.
Nhưng mà ví dụ với cái bài khác đi nó có
bị khuyết đúng không? Tôi muốn xem là
cái median hay là min tốt hơn đúng
không? Thì tôi phải đi sâu vào trong cái
bước này. Thì đi sâu làm thế nào thì các
bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ giả sử bây giẫn
quy ước đấy là gì? Là đầu tiên phải các
bạn cho cái tên của cái bước đã. Tên
bước này nó là gì? Nó là nó là đâu rồi?
A chết nhm nhầm chỗ dưới
đây đúng không? Chỗ dưới này này. Bây
giờ tôi có cái đây đúng không? Tên nó
này đầu tiên là tên của bước là
preprocessor này. Được chưa? Processor
này đúng không? Underscore
trong cái presser này các bạn có ba bước
con đúng không? Ba bước song song nhau
đúng không? No feature, non feature về
order. Mình dùng cái no feature này lại
hai đồ underscore tiếp. Trong cái no
feature á thì nó lại tiếp tục là cái gì?
No fisature thì nó lại hay bớt là gì? Là
imputter với cả scaler đúng không? Thì
ví dụ như nó muốn gửi cái imputer đúng
không? Imputer này. Imputer này đúng
không? Lại hai cái dấu underscore nữa
đúng không? Và mình cái strategy đây
đúng gọi đ không mình ví dụ min mean min
mean min với median kiểu kiểu như này
được chưa? Tức là gì? Cứ tên của cái
bước hai dấu undersore tên bước tiếp
theo hai undersore tiếp theo thì khi đến
cái hyper parameter đấy thì mình dừng
được chưa? Đấy đây là quý để các bạn
tool. Tất nhiên trong bài này như mình
nói rồi nó chả khác gì nhau cả đúng
không? Thế nhưng mà trong bài khác thì
các bạn làm này thì các bạn sẽ phải đi
show và các bạn có thể file tun được xem
là cái bộ giá trị nào nó tốt nhất từng
cái. Ví dụ đây mình cho cái verb bằng 1
cho nó in ít đi thôi nhá. Mình chỉ in
một in nó ít thôi. Được chưa?
Rồi.
Ok rồi đúng không? Đấy đây này m điền
trong này chắc chả khác gì nhau cả nhưng
mà nếu như trong bài khác thì nó sẽ có
hữ nó sẽ hữu ích đúng không? Median này.
Square root này. Được chưa? 100 cây được
chưa? Thế thôi.
Đấy. Sau này khi mà các bạn muốn thay
vào những cái bộ rượu khác, các bạn chỉ
cần thay đổi cái tên ban đầu này, tên bộ
dữ liệu này, tên có thể tên những cái
cột này đúng không? Đúng không? Lăng
cách nó cũng chỉ có ba kiểu đ ba kiểu
tiêu chuẩn đúng không? Nom, Transformer,
Nom Transformer với cả cái còn lại là
các bạn kết hợp cả original với cả
bullin đúng không? Thì sau này các bạn
chỉ đổi tên thôi, đổi cái giá trị nữa là
xong đúng không? Cái khung nó vẫn như
thế. Được chưa? Như chúng ta làm này
chúng ta ch gì? Thành một cái pip hoàn
chỉnh đúng không? Tức là gì? Nếu mà vẽ
ra nó lại như này. Nếu mà vẽ ra ấy lại
như này. Ra như này. Đầu tiên chúng ta
có cái dữ liệu ra như này nhá. Đúng
không? Data như này. Đấy. Đúng không? Ch
mình đi qua cái column transformer nó sẽ
tách thành ba phần riêng này. Đúng
không? Ba phần riêng colum transformer
này đúng không? Đấy. Tách ra thành ba
phần riêng. Sau đó chúng ta lại gộp vào
gộp vào thành một cục này. Cục này nó sẽ
to hơn một tí nó nhiều cột hơn. Sau đó
cho qua cái model ở đây. Cả cái model
hai này thì nó nó thành một cái pipeline
như này. Hang này thành một cái pipeline
đúng không? Đấy. Cho rượu các bạn thả
một phát vào đây cho nó đến cuối cùng nó
ra đây thôi. Được chưa?
như này chưa?
Rồi có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Có nào có tác gì không?
Tất nhiên chúng ta cũng có thể chúng ta
thử cái mô hình khác mà chúng ta lại
dùng lazy PR đúng không? Lazy chúng ta
chạy cả trục mô hình cùng một lố nà thử
nhá. Tương tự như bài trước thôi đúng
không? Trước thôi nào. Laz
này nhá.
Đâu rồi? Question nhá. Được chưa?
Ok rồi. Ok nhất chí nhá.
Bạn nào có lỗi cứ bảo mình nhá. Tí nữa
xong giờ thì mình sẽ ở lại mình rửa cho
các bạn nhá. Đây lazy lại móc vào đây.
Được chưa?
Đây lazy rever này. Được chưa? Anh dùng
tương tự thôi. Hôm nọ dùng nào n dùng
đây chỉ mỗi lầ hôm nọ là lazy
classifier. Cái này là lazy reacer thôi.
Được chưa?
Đây cho cái này vào đây đúng không? Tất
nhiên là chúng ta sẽ không dùng cách
cách chúng ta tiền xử lý đúng không? Ví
dụ mình b tạm đi nhá
tạm đi đúng không? Giờ mình sẽ cho chỗ
ly này được chưa? Exchange exchange này
xd đúng không? Tất nhiên làm như này thì
chúng ta sẽ lại dùng tí ở trên này
exchange xang từ trên này đúng không?
Nếu chúng ta muốn là chúng ta xử lý cách
của chúng ta thì chúng ta phải cho nó đi
qua cái processor này mà thôi nên mình
test nhanh thì mình dùng luôn mặc định
cũng được đúng không? Chạy thử nhá.
Tự đây.
Exchange x testin e test này. Xem cái
xem cái nào cũng được. Model xem cũng
được. Xem prion hai cái như nhau. Xem
cái nào cũng được.
Chạy nó sẽ hơi lâu một tí tại vì là nói
là chạy phải khoảng như là khoảng ba
mươi mấy mô hình thì phải. Nhớ là ba ừ
cũng phải khoảng ba mấy đấy đúng không?
thì xem cái log này nó sẽ biết là chạy
bao nhiêu.
Nay các bạn thử chạy xem có vấn đề gì
không. Đầu chạy nó sẽ hơi lâu một chút.
Rồi có bắt nào có câu hỏi gì không?
Cái này thấy 42 mô hình này. 42 mô hình
thế này. Được chưa?
Xem kết quả như thế nào. Đâu rồi? models
đây rồi đây mà
rồi đúng không các bạn không cần phải
quá nhớ nhá các bạn không cần phải quan
tâm cái việc là các bạn không biết nhiều
mô hình này không biết chuyện bình
thường đúng không vì có nhiều mô hình
tại vì là trong machine có nhiều nó phải
đến 4 50 mô hình khác nhau cơ đây cũng
chưa phải là hết đâu. Thế nhưng mà chúng
ta chỉ cho chỉ cần nhớ những cái mô hình
gọi là ờ cơ bản nền tảng nhất thôi.
Những cái mô hình sau này khi nào chúng
ta thực sự chúng ta cần sử dụng nó nhiều
chúng ta sẽ đi vào chúng ta tìm hiểu sâu
sau không thì các bạn cũng không thể quá
quan tâm chư ạ. Nhưng mình chỗ này mình
chắc là mình cũng chỉ nh biết được
khoảng 2/3 chỗ này thôi còn 1/3 mình
cũng chả biết nó là cái gì. Được chưa?
Rồi
vậy đâ cái classification chúng ta làm
lâu tại vì nó là cái bài đầu tiên đúng
không? Còn reaction bạn nhanh đúng
không? Reaction nhanh đúng không? Thế
thì hôm nay chúng ta hôm nay là chúng ta
xong cái phần liên quan đến rewestion
rồi. Buổi ngày mai chúng ta sẽ học lý
thuyết về à
thứ nhất là lý thuyết về về về mảng NLP
NLP và cả bài toán Charm C forcasting
nữa. Hai buổi thnh tiếp theo chúng ta sẽ
lần lượt chúng ta sẽ làm với ờ NLP tức
là chúng ta cũng sẽ đem machining vào áp
dụng NLP. Chúng ta cũng sẽ nói về việc
là những cái nhược điểm của machining
truyền thống, các cái thuật toàn machine
truyền thống học trong khóa này khi mà
áp dụng vào NP nó như thế nào. Và sau
chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau nói về xem là bây
giờ tôi muốn áp dụng cho cái bài toán
trong bảng time c forcasting thì làm thế
nào nhá.
Ok. Có câu hỏi gì không? Bạn nào mà có
cái chụp chặc gì trong quá trình các bạn
cài ch các bạn code thì các bạn cứ ấm
trên Zalo nhá để tí nữa xong rồi này
mình mình gọi rồi mình xử lý mình mình
fix dùm cho các bạn nhá.
Ok.
Code này mình cũng sẽ up lên trên Google
Drive thế nhưng mà mình vẫn recommend
các bạn là các bạn tự code vị theo theo
cái ý hiểu của mình nhá. Bộ rượu thì vẫn
bài bộ rượu trước rồi các bạn chỉ chọn
cột khác đi lành máy tắn reaction ngay
đúng không? Ng hôm nọ thì cũng khoảng
khoảng lớp mình khoảng hơn 10 bạn gửi
cho mình rồi. Thế hầu hết các bạn đều
làm rất là ok cả. Các bạn làm mỗi bạn
làm một kiểu nhưng mà nhìn nói chung là
khá là ok. Đấy thì mình vẫn recomment
các bạn là gì? Hãy cố làm sao để tự mình
code được theo cái ý hiểu của mình. Thì
lúc ấy khi một khi các bạn đã hiểu rồi
sau này các bạn cứ dùng AI các bạn gen
code các bạn vẫn hiểu nó làm cái gì mà
nhá.
Ok. Cảm ơn mọi người nhá. Mai chúng ta
bắt đầu giờ này nhá.
Mình vẫn để trên mình vẫn để trên link
Google Drive mà. Mình có để lên Google
Drive mà từ trước giờ mình vẫn sau buổi
nào là mình khoảng 20 phút là mình share
đấy rồi mà nhá.
Ok cảm ơn mọi người nha
nhá. Nh up lên đây hết rồi.
By mọi người nha. Mọi người nha.
Bye mọi người nha.
mọi người nha.